soir à tous bonsoir fabas l'accord
miaghri chucky duda sur le live de
bonsoir bonsoir alexander bonsoir jean
christophe bonsoir tout le monde salue
qu'elle s'écrit coûts que saluent kfc
jean-christophe je suis là on salue les
mecs ça fait plaisir que vous soyez là
donc great uk bon comment tu le sens ce
match oui bon bah moi je suis grand
favori du match je suis très heureux car
les qu'ils ne se soient pas qualifiés 1
donc la joue contre jean-christophe duda
donc le mec est classé 2740 faut le
savoir c'est écrit c'est écrit sur le
site de la fif donc je suis grand favori
du match je me suis rasé la tête avant
je suis chaud chaud patate loi jean
christophe comment tu le sens ouais on
va j'ai déjà une écart yakine le dernier
match bon voilà je joue gritche ou que
le mec on va et triple champion du monde
de glisse donc automatiquement dangereux
mais je passe à la télé en pologne donc
je vais le faire pour la pologne
le match est lancé koala sochaux 2 2 ils
sont très chauds et ils sont très chauds
et tu sens que jean-christophe la suite
tu sens que je crie sa fille c'est
plutôt pour la peau jeune agriculteur
une question de fric tu vois mince c'est
pour lui quoi mais parce que tu sens
qu'il ya blad derrière donc qui sent que
tu vois si ramène pas le fric à la
maison la diva le veulent souhaiter quoi
tu sens quand même la puissance de blad
derrière bon mais c'est à bouffer de
coiffure à un look comme moi que je
ouais trop de cheveux un peu de beurre
mais tu sens le côté non rouscoff
maintenant tu sens que va plus plus que
moi je me pose quand même toi son sens
tu es gentil tu as une tête on sent que
tu es gentil gritche ou qu'on sent qu'à
un moment donné
bon il épate un carpaccio si le voilà tu
as tu sens une influence tu vois ces
parties de cet art je ne sais pas tu
sens que si jamais un moment j'en ai une
qui peut de partir dans la gueule du
relationnel de la tnt la suite les gars
est gris cook
ben quoi un fou dégage donc on a une
petite sicilienne je pense que vous
voyez ouais chefferie 4 ailleurs très
énervé l'agriculteur des dès le début la
caméra tu le vois les choses
ça se voit il est très énervé quand le
regard sombre parmi ces gueules sont
distingués comme sasuke
non mais tu sais que c'est hyper vlad
j'ai dit oui mais tu es complètement nu
le tu ne sais pas à jouer comment
peux-tu perdre pour un web c'est de pire
en pire comme un fou vas tu allais jouer
le top 12 l'année prochaine en france vu
ton niveau de jeu peuvent être tombé
aussi bas quoi mais bon tu as refusé de
jouer en pro de chasse ligue avec celle
était avec nous donc forcément c'est ton
mais est ce qu'il a vraiment refuser du
couac romain toujours pas pu tout sera
en fait on ne sait pas c'est pas le
moment on fait ça on n'a pas de réponse
avec nord mais je pense qu'il veut pas y
jouer enfin on saurait si vous voulez
quoi mais il est pas mal d'affaires
d'amd deux gros rock mais où il joue
contre police fighter 3000 quand même
par lui même et à 3000 dans le pseudo à
d'autres n'avaient 299 fin 2009 5 revers
devant lui si trouver enfin un numéro au
point je peux créer mon pseudo mais
surtout que j'ai l'impression que police
fighter ça va pas vraiment avec son
physique tu vas enfin gritche ou que tu
m'aies russe russian oligan ouais
pourquoi pas tu te dis bon on est on est
dans le ton kouame polish fighter pour
pour duda la ive de battre j'ai pas
envie de voir la gueule de l'armée
polonaise sauva par un fou je la sens
pas trop time in the wall fizi perdre
contre eu quelqu'un moins bien classé
que navarra il a compris amine quoi il
il a le
tall flou et très content de la nouvelle
à la nouvelle coiffure de great choc
mais bon vlad est très content de la
part de grisou qu il est pas content que
tu te laisse pousser la barbe
quels sont tes raisons vraiment enfin
es-tu vraiment russes tu vas enfin ça
est très énervé de cette barbe oui j'ai
dit à plat de peut-être que comme plein
de trucs avec lesquels il s'est énervé
dans cinq ans va te retrouver que
l'europe aussi quoi mais en fait c'est
un truc fantastique avec j'adore si vous
voulez une petite anecdote marrante
en fait vlad considérer que les pulls
avec des losanges c'était le niveau zéro
du pull quoique c'était vraiment de la
merde et en fait vous êtes les deux
bords jeu des trucs un peu harlequins
way truc harlequins et des losanges de
merde dessus donc été celui où on
manipule avec dans ses rangs de l'anr
des en fait la preuve ultime de ça c'est
que les coûts emporte donc je trouve
éthiquement bon voilà c'est de la merde
genre tu as perdu le match contre
cramique banque a fait genre la tpu que
c'est de la merde
wal fadjri gagner nos matchs peut-être
qu'on pouvait respecter tpu est donc
donné il me dit ça après iakovenko
commencé en maître donc bon enfin ça
prouve encore plus quoi et à qui un jour
quatre ans après je vois que plus
en fait il met un pull à losanges en
fait me dit non on en fait c'est pas mal
ça la mode quoi juni fab ont fait c'est
si tu vas passer des années à venir que
c'était de la merde qu'il ne faudrait
jamais emporté et que c'était le niveau
zéro du pull quoi tu veux tout d'un coup
je le vous emporter comme j'étais choqué
je suis moi jamais je ne m'abuse
rapporter ces pudeurs j'aurai toujours
tape jamais charge et red bull s'en sont
pas de tout cas rien contre mais du coup
tu t'en vas faire une que son principe
non bah c'est ça moi je vais rien compte
de base et mehdi l'écho emporte donc
c'est des pubs de merde
bon ben moi je la tue à le juger en
mouvement après un jour où croisent
iakovenko avec pourrais je me dis c'est
vrai que vont-ils il ya une corrélation
pas une théorie qui se forme et tout
d'un coup est jouable à dalkia ça va
envoyer des signaux contraires j'ai pas
compris tu vois mais ont du coup moi de
par principe je continue je reste un
pull à lauzon jeu mais ne met jamais ça
avec moi bien sûr jean neuf adjoints du
coup c'est faire la corrélation continue
quoi le truc normal
before qu'un petit peu logo quoi il t'a
pas le truc harlequins de merde de
rothbach bon et du beau gris chaud que
je pense pas qu'il emporte non plus j'ai
jamais vue avec ses pudeurs locale enfin
j'ai jamais vu great food reporter ce
pull marc savard a peut-être mais je
crois que je vis de leurs en mieux c'est
ça commence fort ce serait d'ailleurs
aller les gens réagissent pas trop dans
le chatt là pour le moment mais c'est
quoi ce truc que tu étais des nouveaux
tubes pour qu'on peut parler d'échec et
non par le parti faut aller chez match
je pars à l'échec parce que je ne veux
pas je documente en disant que les coûts
remporte enfin gérons par l'échec
on va du coup il est bien accueilli des
cinq prises il ya lui prendre son pion 5
de merde et puis m
ils émaneraient sur ferrari a aussi mais
ok tu veux prendre 5
il prend un petit flash 4g 5 ne pas voir
le froid arrive en existe à tomber tes
ça m'énerve qu'ils aient par ok avec le
polish fighters battre aucun jour ne
peut pas faire du tour des trois un peu
original on arrête avec les fausses
échec par ailleurs ajusté cash et je
vais faire tour ces trois tours cécile
ici c'est très vrai je pense mais
l'apéro devait les bruits toutes ses
fringues losange du nunavut losange
s'était été très très mal saisies avec
les gens qui ont des idées utiles à
losanges vous déguiser leur le chat
passé c'est fini quoi tu ne peux plus
supporter tué ben laden sur mon tout
premier des six américains
mais ce qu'hier la tour derrière mais il
ne te dirai ce que si on fait rock avec
les noirs on peut tolérer de par là
carlos parce qu'on a une position de
merde non
bon alors fab est et ce qu'on reprend
ton idée est ce qu'on fait fou et 4 bon
pas trop pressé mais pourquoi pas mais
il est repris 4 j'aime bien moi à ce
fantastique femmes
ac non plus ouais donc tu vas faire g5
veut pas devoir de fond f6 toujours la
colonne h potentiellement pour le mec
qu'a pas rock et du coup tu as dû
attaquer son roi et le footballeur a je
crois aussi tapé la tourmente à stx et
fantasy on est très très bien là non
cela doit être aux anges je pense c'est
quoi cette vidéo là où il a créé ou qui
m'attaquent paul toc qui me demandait un
champ c'est ton chat ou ton père qui
était rentré future enceinte je pense
donc bon du coup en plus il est mal
autant non mais c'est génial mais tu vas
y j'espère vraiment ce soir pour une
fois j'espère le scénario du match où tu
vas après une heure s'est bouclée quoi
oui il ya des remises 0 non mais voiture
on regarde mais bon voilà il y aura six
heures guy ritchie qu'en demi ça se voit
ça peut être beau quand même pas moi je
rêve de voir je rêve de voir brad
commenté grille tout con finale en fait
ça peut être fantastique il peut être
super énervé tout le match face à es de
la punchline route menant vers alger 5
il faut calculer ce prise prise tour à
shatura chien fou j'ai son entourage
suite l'automne juste la roulotte et que
c'est pas grave c'est la vente que
j'avais calculé aussi je me disais
qu'après roi 17 évidemment il ya besoin
de ramer sur 27 est ce qu'on peut
appeler vous prend 1,5 puis on prend et
des six le mode de partout il a fait
froid prendre à damas
mais c'est ce qui fait
il en est surveillant ses murs tapions
prend pions prend en tout rachat un
flash un sujet sain il faut cinq pions
prend des six d'amd cette dame prend à
2,5 et gagne à dos la pièce a doublé
double attaque au haillan 8es face à
rennes reste incertain charest avait 12
à l'élan sur la caméra tu sens que la
ffu au cder mais le choc est hyper
énervé c'est génial il fait une tête a
l'impression qu'il ya carpaccio qui
vient de passer le voir ils sont en
train d'y là et lui a dit ils vont
écoute il ya une bavure hier soir où les
deux corps tu vois supporteur du spartak
ouais ses supporteurs du bayern quand
lewandowski
c'est un allemand mickael femmes aux
expressions russes ont même fait leur
retour pour être sûr que faire juste
fois je crois que le père c'est juste
très bien ce qui tue en allemand est bon
pour un russe quoi
d'où la mine the wolf qui dit qu on sait
c est qu il en mode parrain de la mafia
agricole mais c'est ça le golf de me les
deux hoquets bien si tu n'aimes pas je
te prends ta tour tu as c'est ça
l'esprit c'est magnifique en fait ce
qu'est en train de faire mais il peut
pas me prends ce qu'attend procédons à
la dame dont la brève ils pouvaient pas
mais ce paraphe sais mais c'est beau
quand même il a quand même pas faible
bon maintenant on va peut-être faire ton
plan de tours soit troisième engin il à
mettre son rang la bave non ça vous
coûte santoro à piagge et éviter qu'ils
étaient précurseurs curseur au troisième
reich allemand surmonte en quoi elle est
sans tache le plan donc il me la mets
mon cas vous l'a dit donc
automatiquement n'a revêtu à duda il
joue un peu comme contre cariat qui ne
sert que en fait c'est il est résistant
ils arnaquent bien au stade arena
remarquer mme marie pas tu sens que tu
vois il peut enfin pourrait déjà avoir
perdu cette partie quand même bon il ya
peut être eu des si j'utilise mal c'est
à dire que tu vois la gueule des pièces
détourage fuite qui fait rien le fos est
enfermé porte un beau cavalier ou 5 mais
c'est tout quoi ma gueule
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule zhai
se dit peut-être ça n'obstrue sa bande
aux implants prétendre à part en glisse
bon bah c'est 4 mai frb 4 mais on sait 5
cuil on prend
on se calme un plaisir de jouer ça a été
bon mais bon faut pas te retrouves à
l'otan bayon ses griffes s'occupe non
mérité mieux tout le temps mais damon et
i'm ok il va sûrement gagner peut-être
c'est un tour c'est cette non j'ai pas
fait un mois mais il a plein de rage
pour sa part ça rien peut-être pris 4,2
petit change cette tour active autour
ces deux sursis as-tu coût du projet
fera quatre jours le truc ce serait
mange la 3e suite restera enfermé à tout
jamais damas à tous pour ces deux mâles
en tête pour ses 2 go mais il a fait ça
comme paria qui nous aussi puis au bout
d'un moment ça commençait à payer
il fait ce qu'il peut en même temps tu
vois c'est pas un joueur de notamment de
cette trempe encore peut-être un jour
les fruits qui est très jeune et déjà de
1700 et quelques symboles et de presque
27 41 je crois à temps je vais te dire
ça ce que tu as une info officielle
choisi de nous le faut
alors attends donc temps il faut que je
tape fidh et duda je vais te donner je
vais te lâché une info la fab
c'est une info officielle by les 2739 il
est dans 98 temps actuels à 20 ans et
lui l'a pas devenu champion du monde
juniors lui nous intéresse pas lui ça
intéressait pas mais tu m'avais c'est
parce que bon il ya mêmes magoo douce ou
machin qui a gagné le l'iranien voyez
très très fort un genre s'est passé je
ne veux surtout pas parce que les mecs
sera peut-être dans le top 20 mondial
d'ici quelques années
c'est très très possible il est vraiment
impressionnant mais je ne dira pas que
des jeunes qui sont forts enfin gérard
sont en fait qu'aujourd'hui quand tu
gagnes un championnat jeunes qui corse
et déjà dire que tes parents tu as tes
pas dans les meilleurs jeunes n'ont même
blum où il est pas mal il est pas mal
mais je n'apparais que les plus forts
participe plus du tout aux trucs jada
moi je passe il est le plus fort c'est
tout
je passe en a beaucoup dans son coeur en
fête ben oui il a quel âge
ouais c'est vrai ça fait quand même deux
essais bahdja souvenirs c'est non mais
évidemment quand on était au dessus du
lot tu vas pas les jouer contre les
enfants
tu vas direct chez les grands ou tu te
fait surclasser ou quoi c'est plus
ambitieux c'est beaucoup moins évident
99 oui il a 19 ans approche là dessus
c'est beaucoup plus important d'autres
vouloir devenir un joueur aguerri et
être un foreur un jour que d'empiler des
titres jeunes qui en fait ok mais dans
quinze ans qui va se faire petit jeune
et et justes ouvertes on y voit ce
moment là non mais c'était juste voilà
j'ai juste ça comme ça par rapport comme
comme il ya le championnat du monde la
junior qui s'est fini à il ya quelques
jours c'était juste pour rebondir sur le
fait qu'à une maxime magnifique
performance de l'iranien est quand même
ses titres jeunes aux échecs en tout cas
on vraiment perdu de leur valeur soit
plus tout le monde n'ya plus tôt fait de
la gare il a été champion du monde
juniors
battu à l'époque y avait tout le monde
en fait oui mais je somme il ya vingt
ans et c'est vrai dans à peu près toutes
les catégories derrière oui on voit bien
que ces petits double à nantes 700
fiches au web après avait un gamin de 12
ans
qui a joué tableau 1 en moins de vingt
ans jean seront de 4 ou 5
alors du coup oui mais voilà il s'arrête
sur place et ça c'est que la 13 14 ans
en fait déjà ils sont sur place pour
jouer ça passe ça les intéresse pas
tabriz âge il a déjà joué un champion du
monde juniors mais voilà c'est ce qu'ils
font en fait c'est qui ce surclasse
quand ils sont petit puis après ils n'y
vont plus quoi faire quoi ouais mais
c'est pour rebondir sur le fait que 12 a
été un des joueurs les plus talentueux
de sa génération
clairement c'est sûrement le meilleur
sondage je pense oui donc et si on l'a
pas vu briller dans les compétitions je
vois c'est pour résumer la prestation
n'a pas vu la brillé dans les
championnats du monde juniors les
consciences humaines c'est juste qu'il
est trop fort pour les jouets et quelque
part ça prouve qu'il est au dessus
désormais trop fort ou pas en fait on va
le jouer veulent gagner de jeu c'était
pas gagné d'avancé
non mais bon c'est plus intéressant de
faire le speech est de préparer première
table des olympiades avec la pologne
élus des thrillers à la première table
c'est un ski à gauche et à sa collègue
paul berry qui nous donne je testais
qu'aux deux premiers c'est pas mal et
après tu as des bons mecs à 2006 très
correct dégager de ce qui est des mecs
comme sa cagette ce qui d'ailleurs a été
second dans deux cramique non ils
deviendront de la nand par compass de
crâne bout
excuse moi je voulais dire à nant dgg
mélange est vrai mais de cramique pas du
tout en fait un choix il a eu aucun
rapport
bon autant jeter beaucoup en commun il
s'était glissé t à nantes que je vais
dire faire est clairement et puis il ya
ceux qui dans le nom qui est un joueur
de tuba c'est fou dre taratata doux data
va acheter un sac sur avons eu ici un
peu après ta les squats à ibiza ce
qu'ils y arrivent ce qui est en fait
sinon le second temps et coach depuis
très longtemps d'audace et mis ton
destin bah ouais car elles n'ont qu'à
rennes
ouais mais s'annonce trucs comme ça
karen carell cas
i took my habito karen ce camp russe et
un nombre minimal ce qui correspond jeu
s'entend plus mille dames il ya mis le
mythe on sait quand la voiture
ben oui j'en sais qu'en 2000 oui ces cas
là c'est pas mon cas de quoi s'est dit
d'accord aux équipes se donne lui enfin
je l ai fait canon kara incarnons k2k
mille quoi merde c'est générale en fin
de soirée lui dire un jour qui anime le
bien que 2000 quand j'étais petit c'est
fantastique comme série consacrée à
votre équipe
chez puma était géniale cette voiture
l'agencé simca 1000 noms voiture deux
mines le kit qui touche 10 e ledy un
truc comme ça chez puisque italie enfin
le replay pour savoir répondu qu il sait
me dit quoi
je suis marocain on va faire des cinq la
fable on en a marre qu'on va le
cinquième lieu 4 dégâts je comprends ton
pion de merde et je t'attaque des quatre
pages en vis un cahier la bouffe bouffe
et je bouffe des cats tu bouffes de la
tour et je te fais fou prend des quatre
arrivées en fait on mettrait logique
d'arrêt 0 ce n'est pas de se laisser
marcher dessus
c'est typique un jeune structure
française un peu dans l'esprit
quoique et par voilà est en baisse de 6
pour éventuellement transmettre des fois
tu vas aussi donc fabriqué no 6 qui
pourra faire un peu quarterbacks de la
position et sinon aussi balancer ses
cinq évident que c'est le centre mais la
contrepartie c'est que vu ta de cette
structure au blanc qui penche un peu
varié droit avec des 4,5
cela redonne plus d'espèces de ce côté
et donc lui il vient il vient en nombre
à risque penchant t'as pas peur de
tanguay bah ouais mais bon tant que ça
tiens tiens on à tour de pise
c'est un joueur s'effondrera l'instant
elle est là que j'allais l'avoir du coup
est ce qu'on peut faire du tout
reprendre cinq pions blancs et cavalli
pour un f2 bout je dois retrouver notre
découverte de ce soit garde
bon après quitte à prendre aux 5 autant
prendre un peu cavalier peut-être rue de
la tour après je me disais qu'il est
peut-être faire cailler g6 changer si
sky et f4 tu vois et genre enchaîner
après avec tout reprendre 5 qui on prend
qui éprouvent deux échecs et rebondir en
h3 double échec fut assez fou doubla non
nous les chèques faut trouver une suite
quoi penser comme toi - oui vraiment bof
une pièce mais bon tu peux toujours
argumenter que tu es plus dans l'esprit
que lui et enfin tu as et c'est sur
pareil mais le repas 2005
ces 5 2 5g quatre paquets g3 je te
bouffe des paquets de catch que bush
je te veux me retrouve dans l'esprit à
fond évidemment grille tout cas c'est
avec si j'écoute si j'ai quatre étaient
possibles tutu prend peur audi a donné
j'ai quatre sur tempo
alors ya mes soeurs bédouins qui nous
dit si j'avoue que si duda offre une
nouvelle surprise là on dirait que
j'achète
alors est ce que mr t soit souhaite se
faire bannir du chat
c'est dommage qu'on le connaît il est
assez sympa jusque là elle a tout d'un
coup tu vois heureusement qu'il ya pavla
d'un parce que la foule mais les bouffes
des kataëb ont coûté 4,2 pour le court
étoile je regarde l'équipe de pologne
aux olympiades des hockeyades août à
volta sac évidemment mais là y'a pas
gâcher ce qui est absurde n'y est pas
mal mais il n'y a pas eu vol et 26 12
mai bon joueur bayer s'est casper van
west casper comme le petit fantôme
et là il est partout comme ça qu il ya
sept top chaque état non d'autres chaque
voiture en couture ac et dragoons
aliochine être prêt donc une bonne
petite équipe sous pas mal
camille c'était un chiffre et du dragon
tu haïras le dragon pour une lettre pas
de chance ça et c'est dommage ça c'est
dommage
taillefer dragon quest 1-1 au scrabble
et est dégoûté que la tv line is titre
est il te reste cinq lettres ta dragoon
coiffe à tunis à hello je faisais dragon
quoi j'ai le droit
bah c'est peut-être passé comme ça en
fait ses parents il fait il ya des
lettres comme ça ils ont fait ça et
faire un prénom et puis ils ont dû faire
le oud quoi king martin qui nous aussi
on te dit bonjour aussi le roy martin 17
bon en tout cas ça sent encore pas mal
bon pour get choc grosse avance à la
pendue une qualité d' avance mais très
envie d'échanger les dames c'est déjà
faire f 5 maintenant moi je l'aurais pas
fait mais montpezat tu y vas faire même
lui ne fait pas ce qui prouve que
c'était vraiment pas un bon coup vous
vous êtes inverse
peut-être cette fois plus doux il a fait
tomber un f5 avec pas mal de retard
ils seront qualifiés 3 sur tempo à
l'époque j'avais un clavier ou quatre
charges était en avance sur ton temps
quoi hein comme tout le monde
cg ahmad moussa nous sommes bien en
avance sur les joueurs wii ils font les
coups qu'on propose avec 10 coups de
retard mais il n'est pas facile à finir
se rendre en iran est fou mais je crois
que c'est quand le mot qui colle à ce
qu'ils essaient de nous faire est
souvent vécue non mais c'est petit paumé
jarry s'accroche
vas tu as épreuves de grand talent de
l'armée c'est bien s'accrocher pas
attention il faut il avait gagné le
match comme ce soir en s'accrochant que
non mais j'aime bien ce pas je respecte
tu vois pas ok déjà on n'a jamais ya une
partie d'échecs en abandonnant le sais
quoi et c'est bien dans le fighting
spirit
les anglais au foot quoi l'ariary
maskaev six échecs comme liverpool en
2005 et deux et trois zéro métro pie ix
tu te bats je n'ai pas trop aimé cette
finale ah tiens tu es tombé
tombé kong beach oct voilà après great
chioukh là il joue un peu plus vite
aujourd'hui à faut quand même
reconnaître que comme reach ou qui vous
vite et bien
c'est très dangereux donc oui ou non le
statut ouverture du score de de
tottenham sur la pelouse de l'inter but
de qui ericsson nous donnons lui aussi
une lettre avoir de téléphone et
ericsson comme ça c'est génial et ils
sont tous à une lettre ce soir 100 kg
du coup se passait au c'ur prof de déjà
vu ce thème l'idée des normes de
papattes prendre car si ça arrive il y
aura un échange
et alors ça sécurise du coup l'acca de
saint cloud tout cas venu mais bien
juteuse affaire un peu comme dans la
partie karlsson vosges taceq qu'on avait
d'ailleurs fait sur la chaîne entre
sphère le grand roque avec le fils de
chien ghetto qui nous avait paru très
solidaire fab second qu'étonnamment ont
été solides en les vidant clairement ça
se défend bien alors après mon genre
structure qui peut te dire on est
peut-être le fruit mûr autres hop tu
fais 4 ou h4 taper sur g 5 mai mais bon
tu craches une grosse diagonale tu
prends la casse ces quatre ça c'est très
intéressant
joker5 des fois il vient t'embêter
verser 4 voilà nous mettra pas grand
monde ni trop justement j'ai donc pas
mal et s'il va faire f3 h4 du coup de la
peur sur autre chose
il navigue et le four rf1 du coup a pas
pu faire juste juste acheter notamment
fait c'est ce que je vais avec les faits
je lui dis camaïeu de f4
bon attention tout va changer mais ça
qui me prendre un cavalier 9,4 les
tentes des sacrifices sur os 6 2 1
bayrou c'est signifie gérer réfléchissez
ce plan pas j'aime ma seule amène à
traiter de la position de ce qu'on fait
à trois là ils sont rares sur b4 à 4 sur
l'a4 des cats
mais bon j'aime parce que gris qui
accueille ses katas prêt serait plus du
robot
moi je ferai du cavalier f3 la fal un
grand bien
il prépare t froid tout vent il protège
des f3 qui va arriver
t'as vu ta tête et était précurseur sur
le coup quoi on me reviens tu fais
toujours nombreuses
mais au pays il faut comprendre inquiet
sur ses seins nus et après je vais pas
faire kf3 ben je sais pas une beauté
rare et damas est vous conviens mais
j'ai fait je fais abcb1 ebooks adam
benhamma cet écouteur quand bien même
nom mais le fait qu'elle est étroit et
c'est la même idée et c'est mieux parce
que venir sur ces 1 tu peux venir sur b4
et tant d'autres le caillou c'est la
même chose en plus fort puisque tu es en
train de nous dire m il a pris nos deux
idées il était bon que les aveux de
qu'on a chacun voit son truc moi je fais
deux en un un petit peu car un shampoing
un peu mais y'a pas que les shampoings
je pense que c'est très loin même des
coûts qu'aux déchets par e-mail astatke
prend 1,5 et on prend 1,5 et kf3 aussi
ce qui est du coup le client et 5e pas
défendre mon honneur et je trouve que je
me bats écoute
[Musique]
je peux te dire que s'ils pouvaient
gagner le speech s il serait quand même
trésor pour lui c'est comme un titre tu
vas safra titre cette année je sais que
j'aime bien les titres et la mixité ou
pas et puis au moins tu retiens ça dans
ta carrière
et le jour où tu t'arrêtes ou quoi d'un
groupe heure de paris et christophe
voter titre passait 2e place et b4 ou
qe3 ne peut pas faire à 3 éventuellement
wayne lui fera trois des quatre à quatre
et du coup je tiens a cassé quatre vies
domicile ipv4 non mais probablement chez
du dessin quelques jours je me marché
postal tout cas great food qui est
vraiment prêt ce soir car il joue bien
et je joue vite aussi on sent que valve
a dû fouetter avant de jouer un japon a
recommandé la veille 5 et peut-être
aussi motivée par le tableau qui s'est
bien découvert dans sa partie de tableau
puisqu'il jouera le vainqueur de guiry
vi de saut visite et que normalement
contre souris sera encore favori donc
c'est vrai que s'il s'applique il peut
faire peut s'offrir une finale contre
contre nac a wave et elles sont comme
les favoris de l'autre partie les
tableaux non 5 et rognant sur internet
c'est moins ça ça reste correct on verra
je dis d'ailleurs à rognan guéri plus
fort heureux
la vie sauvage qui comprend très bien le
système dit de toute façon quand richard
joue bien c'est grâce à vlad et quand il
perd c'est de sa faute vabre et c'est
peut-être ça fait un résumé deuxième but
du barça
semaine 2 0 écoute les carottes sont
cuites pour leurs adversaires
on dirait encore un but de messi nom de
dembélé a alors français du coup de
blues
caa-québec assez bien joué et il a
complètement éteint une nouvelle fois
très bien ce que je dise
du coup est ce que tu fais du fouet
pharma non pardon peut-être du fouet f1
même à eux
pourquoi pas très intéressant arm est
déjà là on a coupé toutes les velléités
noir sur les dames très bonne première
étape
jojo qui espère pas avoir un 30 0 n'ont
plus beaucoup de moi s'ils gagnent 30 0
sur les comptes en fin ou kelly
d'empêcher le 5 c'est important c'est au
500m important pour les blancs
d'acétylène si tu peux faire sur fun
mais maintenant voir cette enquête peut
être des saints on peut aussi faire un
truc un peu cool lui c'est qu'il y ait
des cinq crises et se libérer la can
avec ed après m'être le four lui 4e ça
tu te souviens même et elle tend
désormais à l'énorme empattement enfin
je vois pas ce qu'ils font donc autant
qu'on améliore un peu à se faire peur
sur ses trois tours servent à la raison
l'a emporté 3-2 fauteurs de série sont
des six a faim tu te fait mariner quoi
oui un petit peu comme un plat écho plus
il ya besoin d'une marinade de se tenir
ouais ouais c'est simple à 2 senior tour
c'est un j'aime bien en fait un homme
est pourquoi pour vous ce que vous il
c'est ton plan femmes
bon ok déjà faux
on se demandait si tu en prends des
cistes sepa forme d'amande heures qu'est
ce qu'ils préparent à greccio le père
riccio que j'ai envie de dire la tête
hors de l'eau amd un bon jeu pourquoi un
bon ok dessin qui est toujours
d'actualité quoi qu'il en soit on prend
il faut 4 berné il a peut-être avec
juste deux sacrifiés sur des sites en
bout des six vous faut cinq à
cloche-pied b2 ça va quand même pas le
bâton car il y avait quatre c'est un
cavalier de seniors aux siens enfin à
l'autre il est peut-être possible c'est
rh 4g 5
bon j'ai gagné vous raterez de fer tour
g1 h4 g5 et mon toit au-dessus des loges
de qualifier sa patte à la casse des
cinq pour toi et ton fric trois pôles me
ranger 4
c'est de l'échangé vendre le fou 17 et
pouf ou des noirs c'était un après tu
rice a ramené le carillon des cinq avant
et tutti quanti quoi j'ai envie de tenir
et tutti frutti
c'est tous les fruits tutti frutti corps
qui n'est pas une chanson de elvis 1 ces
deux reprises nick h 4 h 5 est fou c'est
un sagan oui mon adversaire ne va pas
dormir en face à un vent plus hkd g5
plus tôt quand même c'est le candidat
qui réagit bien
mais j'aime pas trop comment grichka
jouer les dix derniers coups honnêtement
que finalement il va réussir la fac et
c5
il va attaquer la tour b 3 il va
attaquer le pion b3 et il s'est ré
agencer fabi serre est agencé
je vois je sais pas pas si grave voire
famille l'un plus en plus faut que tu
fasses quelque chose là
fabre n'est juste mal la nano fourrage
qu'axpo la bonne nouvelle fab comment
que pourquoi on fait quoi maintenant
fin juin qui est là bien géré on perd la
partie et on commence une autre on s'en
fout ouais ok tu as raison on va donc du
coup m'abandonne quoi fin des gammes de
bukumu inquiète vous asseyez que je suis
plus joueur qui en fait ce fait je m'en
fous complètement que la fin c'est pas
grave mais grichka fait un métier à ce
doux travail exactement comme ça qu'il a
battu car yakine cf
nathan sage ou encore sa iroko pause et
pourrait faire tomber s'ils sont partout
on va voir c'est évidemment beaucoup
moins écrasant tout ça était ne sait
plus trop écrasant des eaux mais bon
c'est pas bref en tout temps les
manières de faire
j'en ai marre parce que les 6,5
vachement souffert tf 5 est enfin tant
pis pour hrw pour la qualité pas de
chance tu la donnes et tout actif de
folie et tu vois ça il n'apprend pas
c'est laura femmes
non c'est pas bien tu comprends pas ce
qui s'est passé fable finalement le tour
j'ai un machin a mal marché
ce que nie la bêtise et iris a full tilt
et à déconvenue lors j'ai pas pu non
plus mais bonne organisation des pièces
de bouddha donc c'était chiant mais du
coup ok c'est que l'art s'est émue pour
les blancs il fallait juste éviter ce
plan juste la foi de m
bien joué de la part de duda géorgie
dont après la joute peut répéter sa
lumière
il n'y a pas de raison de changer de nom
mais on sent que duda tu vois il est
changements de ligne non
ouais tu as envie non non mais pour sa
chance et bien là il prend sa chance
puisque c'est ici où sache en classe
affaire bizarre mais deux dames se soit
fait fou g4 donc il ya donc ils
repartent sur moi je suis de 15,8 et
s'inquiètent justement quand karine a
ainsi que film et pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
enfin il fallait que je la mette une
fois cette chanson sur live n'ont donc
jamais seul mais je pense qu'elles aient
droit d'auteur aussi pour le marché
jamais ça je peux sûr je suis quasi sûr
fabre il ya les droits d'auteur de
partout c'est hallucinant le fruit de
votre des droits d'auteur si tu marches
jamais seulement 15 secondes ça va
normalement ces cinq ya pas faire des
pauses genre une minute on peut plus
rien faire le ballon tu vas tu le mets 5
secondes face à hawk est étonnant j'ai
déjà vu roustan mais dans ces vidéos
quoi peut-être non mais c'est à ses
risques et périls quoi tu ne peux pas
savoir
tu peux être embêté comme pas ça dépend
s'il ya de la nuit nuisances en face ça
dépend de ouèssè l'europe mais après
tard une épée de damoclès
c'est à dire qu'à tout moment en phase
de strike à tout moment tu peux avoir un
problème
après ça peut ne jamais tomber dessus
s'effacer comme tout en fait
by claude rich ou qu'est-ce qui va faire
fou machin face à l'accueil des cartes
il faisait cap o keeffe 3 tu te bats
gouverner prod'homme ne pas le faire et
tg4 sepa sont plus vulnérables enfin
pourquoi frégé cas du coup tu peux même
pas me faire f3 mais bon t'as tes potes
qui est des 5 fu des nuitées ou hi5
j'aurais jamais fait non mais bien sain
mais bon ça qui peut donner un cycle où
quang nam son sillage et 4g 5 un levier
non match et j'aime pas en fait fâcheux
ne fait que tu as fait bien tu ne les as
rien puisque surprise prises soient sont
atteints non seulement doit tout à son
père mais attend que ceux qui
réussissent en prison d'après méprendre
égalisation de ligne ter de icardi avec
la 36e minute
j'adorerais cette fois deux buts de
messi et cie doubler dans les métis est
triple il ya 3 heures roger est injuste
j'ai dit que c'est plus un rouge donc
voilà partis fou de foot aux multiples
l'oubli des karatékas qui est des 4 et
d4 bonbons et des gâteaux trophy
je pense que tourner great choc en fait
c'est ce que puisque 20 il est peut-être
des fous prend 1,6 mêmes qui vont
arriver là oui bien sûr que j'ai eu 10 h
6 mai notons à voir en tout cas si
douglas e requalifie sera terminée
normes surprise en cette année de la
part de duda je serais quand même très
surprenant mais donc attend avec ses
histoires droits d'auteur j'ai une
question quand je vais dans un resto ou
un bar éclat et la musique
ouais ils ont droit de la musique bat
normalement ils paient des droits à la
sacem vrai mais genre les télés tout ça
ils paient des droits évidemment t'as
pas le droit de mettre une télé outre la
redevance
mais c'est normal en cette femme non
mais je suis dis qu'il faut des
questions je connais pas vraiment fait
tout ça c'est super normal c'est comme
chasser comme des rats six canadiens se
disent bon bah je vais prendre leurs
commentaires du speech est vois ce que
je veux dire mais le droit d'auteur et
pas assez bien respecté en général ils
ont fait de nos danseurs ont voté un
truc européen oui oui oui mais ils ont
fait un truc et du coup il ya un gars de
mateur qui étaient très mécontents
non mais vraiment une personne qui est
très mécontent du droit d'auteur en
finir je ne peux plus utiliser le
contenu que j'ai envie pour mes vidéos
les photos de tout le monde mais mais en
fait le droit d'auteur c'est bien fait
rire ça protège des auteurs en réalité
non mais vraiment bien sûr je comprends
bien l'idée jeu j'ai assez souffert
entre guillemets de ça parce que j'écris
des déchets qui sont familiers ou
piratés et quand on fait des master
classes seront sans doute aussi que du
piratage et machin donc ok je suis
habitué à me mets donc je pose une
question suivante
ouais en fait après c'est pas sûr qui
fait après tu as des amendes si elles
sont pas payés au kwat à des amendes
après je sais le seul truc que je sais
pas avec la musique c'est ce qui se
passe tu passes la radio mais si tu
penses que tu veux je me sens ni je
pense que l'auteur touche de l'argent
ouais mais en fait après le truc c'est
un peu le même système qu'à la télé
c'est qu'en fait tu rediffusé à plus de
gens donc après ça dépend quelle télé ce
dépend de quelle radio évidemment pour
les pour les chaînes payantes tu ne peux
pas ça c'est sûr après si c'est france 2
ou france 3 où tf1 qui de toute façon
sont des chaînes gratuites tu vois je ne
sais pas ok mon pote tu veux faire 10 5
ou ses options
juste pour couper un peu le chouchou des
gens et pourquoi antar yahia de
maternelle en fait ça aucun rapport en
fait c'est une private joke haifa vous
faites avec les ok le truc il ya une
vraie histoire des règles motors c'est
que enfin quand il fait ses vidéos il
pour les rendre plus sexy
il te piquent les photos prises sur
place par les photographes et au bout il
a fait le dessin et il a il a fait ça
récemment pendant la signe que fils ou
je sais pas quoi saint-louis quoi et et
donc il fait ses belles miniature cvo
machin il illustre avec ses belles
photos et en fait au quai saint louis
ils sont pas super heureux parce que ils
payent des photographes mais perry
venons ici de base et les vêtements et
dans les listes où et c'est pas pour qu
un charlot à ray charles ou pas c'est
pas ça votre lit mais que quelqu'un vite
je ne te plier n'ont manqué à ce vide
l'air et il ya eu un clash
ils sont le trou sur twitter bon après
un truc papoul c'est qu'il a filé
l'adresse mail hagen motors de d'une
meuf qui travaillent au club de saint
louis est en fait tous ses followers
sont mineurs et les mails d'insultés
donc c'est un peu parti en vrille à
issoire à ranger ledroit finalement je
vois bien même si en fait c'est ça fait
voilà et ça c'est pour ça qu'on leur
parle des fois
d'après nous on n'a rien à voir là
dedans sont faits en fait complètement
mais mais oui et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il décennies slideshow quand je
faisais parce qu'il a vraiment fait un
message pour alerter les gens ce qui est
très mécontent du truc de droits
d'auteur et justement il écrivait plus
ou moins que ça les empêche pas
d'utiliser les photos qu'il envie
d'utiliser par un tueur est ce que venir
alors que la belle on s'en fout que des
photos mais mais du coup on fait juste
comprends pas trop quand et créateurs de
contenu normalement content que le
contenu soit
soit protégé tu vois après des trucs qui
sont tolérés leurs parents prizee talent
c'est plus ou moins toléré d'utiliser
son truc parce qu'il ya des millions de
gens qui l'utilisent et que finalement
ils font jamais rien qu'ils sont très
heureux que résultats soient connus quoi
un jo je veux pas dire ok je dis pas
mais
mais voilà pour l'histoire de
de notre inside au coût des poils on
rigole avec favre avec ça sa nouvelle
vie dans l'histoire en fait pas un
enfant vous en veut tellement s'en fiche
c'était ça le fond de l'histoire à le
fond de la faire mais font de la faire
cuire une très bonne émission sur
youtube pour ceux qui connaissent pas su
qu nefab non mais de beaucoup plus
qu'avec youtube pour des fonds de la
faire c'est pas mal mais faut être allé
en fait c'est un truc vraiment
sérieusement bien c'est pas bien parce
que c'est ridicule
s'il est d'accord pour les photos mais
malheureusement que les coûts des input
partis ne sont pas protégés alors ça se
fait ça ne sera jamais protégé ça peut
pas être le cas parce que sinon ça
voudrait dire je suis protégé les coûts
d'une partie que d'un autre joueur
n'aurait pas loin de la reproduire
genre je mettrais un brevet sur la sho
pas moins une italienne et pis-aller
d'études tu viens de rejouer la partie
gain de jouer ça n'arrivera jamais ça ne
pourra jamais arriver en revanche ce qui
va arriver pendant la coupe du monde le
match pour le championnat du monde hi fi
de fab c'est qu'une nouvelle fois la
retransmission des coûts ne va pas être
autorisé non répond ouais et il ya un
précédent dans la justice américaine
c'est un précédent nfl fab ou la nfl a
gagné un procès en disant que tu n'avais
pas le droit de donner les scores des
matchs de football américain en direct
tu dois attendre trente secondes avant
d'avoir deux nuls le droit donné c'est
parce que comme la nfl et organisatrice
et qui payent des milliards d'euros
entre les joueurs les organes
l'organisation de de la compétition et
cetera le tribunal a jugé qu' évidemment
tu avais pas le droit de protéger une
information comme un score quand même le
droit de parler quoi mais qu'ils avaient
le droit d'avoir un jour davantage
industriels jugent pas comme on appelle
ça de 30 secondes pour que leur que leur
que leur site en fait nfl.com soit plus
intéressant que les fins qu'ils aient un
avantage sur les sites concurrents
qu'ils soient qui reste un avantage qui
n'est pas écrasant quoi donc considérer
que les sept ceux des cartes de 30
secondes mais du coup de choc sera aussi
un petit décalage ou pas du tout
barrigue on veut le faire en tout cas
pour le match du championnat du monde
mais non mais c'est un des gages 30
secondes en fait trente secondes
devraient normalement je pense à
surmonter pour savoir la joie soudan
après j'avais gagné le produit avait
perdu le procès la dernière fois contre
cech 24 mai et ont perdu mais moi en
fait je suis assez pour ce truc de 30
secondes
parce que maman maintenant faut qu'on se
font que les échecs devienne un business
et c'est pas possible de vivre que sur
l'argent public tout le temps tout en
tout le temps tout le temps et de rien
faire pour aider à les organisateurs
privés et des gens tu as acquis mais en
fait c'est leur événement ils ont
investi ça coûte quand même 5 millions
d'euros tu vas donc j'imagine casse fin
pour moi 5 millions d'euros taquin le
droit de coter photo ne soit pas
réutilisé par un parent à youtuber landa
et que et que tonton kéké côté coûts
soient protégés avec 30 secondes
ça me tue à ça me paraît pas n'est pas
pas délirant personnellement non moins
de 30 secondes ça change grand chose
mais surtout qu'en fait quand tu cites
envoie une demande pour utiliser les
photos est tout petit répond toujours
positivement d'ailleurs si tu leur hymne
au moins d'être écrit les crédits quoi
ouais non mais si tu écris te disent
toujours oui je sais ce que quand on
fait les réseaux sociaux avec chaises
comme en fait on écrit et ça nous est
jamais arrivé que ce soit refusée en
fait d'utiliser les photos mais genre
jamais pas pas une seule fois à un
tournoi qui a maintenant mais par contre
des formes et aux deux oui ma cité qui a
fait des photos alors jojo qui gagne
déjà s'efface tu penses que les tournois
d'échecs gagne déjà assez les
organisateurs de tournois ils souffrent
ceux qui n'ont pas si tu es un
organisateur privé que t'as pas de fonds
publics derrière c'est très difficile et
pataky demande kevin est ce que tu
penses que 30 secondes ça change tout
alors peut-être pas pour les échecs mais
c'est toujours mieux
enfin tu aura toujours des gens qui
iront sur ton site regardez quand même
plus de gens forcément
enfin d'après moi femme ça rigole quand
même un avantage ce truc des trente
secondes we put façon dont tu es le truc
officielle et voilà après ils auront les
caméras les machins et sata son ca
s'était protégé de base on parlera pas
aussi le truc c'est ça c'est en fait les
autres sites en fait tu ne diffuse pas
l'événement a été filmé pas 45 en train
de feu sékou et machin en fait c'est
comme quand de voir des live écrit sur
l'équipe ou quoi machin et passe à
truquer ben alors menacé carl scène joue
son pion là qu'en gros on va se battre
nous on a un code c'est au 4 mai mais
bon du coup on peut pas empêcher ça non
et c'est normal qu'on puisse le faire
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on puisse
retransmet clés que vous m'aimez mais
bon le truc des trente secondes
je pense à peu poussé des gens allaient
voir le truc vraiment en direct je sais
pas trop j'ai pas femmes pour les échecs
peut-être moins pour d'autres sports on
met évidemment mais l'avait fait la fête
pendant 30 secondes de retard le carnage
de foot
la belle affaire ouais après ray whitney
mais bon c'est quand même un argument
marketing pour qu'ils parlent en faveur
de ton site
non mais sur un truc en fait à la gueule
là peut-être pour ce match là ça
changera pas des masses mais quand tu va
retransmettre le choc des mondes de
blitz ou des choses comme ça la wii
torre a 30 secondes c'est beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de résultats qui arrivent en
blitz
oui il y aura d'autres moments on sera
plus important donc qu'il fasse valoir
leurs droits que déjà la soie une petite
différence est que d'autres fois sur une
plus grande différence à une cause berki
ces images sont toujours un il ya aussi
le truc des paris en ligne
et s'il fait des paris en ligne que ce
soit sur le tennis sur le machin là ça
devient important les 30 secondes
non mais donc oui pourquoi c'est normal
que les oreilles et surtout on va pour
pour finir là-dessus fallait repartir
sur sur les parties et en plus les
organisateurs des chèques et ceux qui
font des photos et tout c'est un ça
n'arrive jamais qui te laisse pas les
droits et nous l'ajusterons pour le truc
de saint louis avec check point com
enfin il n'y a pas eu un seul problème
ya pas une seule fois où ils ont refusé
qu'on comprenne leur photo pas une
simple c'est plutôt mieux d'être en bons
termes et à sang ils sont montés à
baisser c'est pour ça que tu demande la
permission machin auxquels ils sont
contents toute façon on parle d'art
l'événement ils sont pas là juste pour
ce pour s'enfermer dans leur cave
donc on a les mêmes et d'aller tout
pillé un contenu sans demander ça j'aime
pas et bon mais bon là du coup l union
européenne va aussi renforcer les lois
pour éviter ça mais surtout qu'en face
quand tu te sens tu fais ta vidéo si
wayne on met à sac après les miniatures
nous on n'y fait pas attention pas parce
qu'on est surtout plus sur le contenu
plus sur le fond que sur la forme en
fait mais c'est vrai que c'était cité
c'est vrai que c'est utile d'avoir une
odeur de soufre ozone
c'est vrai que c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est important d'avoir une bonne
miniature ça te fait plus de clics
mais bon après nous là on peut pas on
peut pas comparer ces nous on s'en
occupe à tort d'ailleurs on devrait plus
le faire mais oui mais c'est vrai que la
technique de mettre la photo le machin
mais moi je sois fois écrire demander
les droits d'auteur attendre pour
pousser ta vidéo par ses longs à chaque
fois ici c'est pas ça prend du temps
quoi donc voilà fabre cette petite
partie j'ai bien aimé le g4 faut jamais
en fait les replacements de fou toujours
été fan de ce truc là de remettre ton
fois en chantier tôt même si là je
n'aime pas spécialement la position de
duplicata me faut trois et autres c4
consul est une joie d'autres cas les a5
du coq entre 4 et 9 ans il a changé il a
il a conquis duda aussi que ça nasdaq ça
allait pas et ça se passe mieux dans le
dans la pétrole tout il reviendra mais
mac os x il veut en revenir il reviendra
mais megan nash d'arc est un grand
maître argentin
[Musique]
les pulls polos ouais en fait il a vécu
là bas je connaissais un russe à moscou
qui s'appelait micha aussi donc mirail
et volé pour l'appel me guen mais je
sais pas pourquoi on fait donc peut-être
que tu es l'été michal et qu'après 2020
enfin c'est le même prénom à l'hormadi
tout le monde c'est vrai que c'est un
avantage alors les blancs aux échecs ou
est tout à fait en tête étaient mieux
avec les blancs au début en début de
partie était heureux d'avoir les blancs
ce que tu commences donc tu donnes un
peu le ton de la partie ça on peut
comparer ça me ferait comme un service
au tennis à l'initiative quoi tu
commences obtus de meubles de style de
partie que tu as envie
voilà après après c'est moins grave que
ça a sauté sur le coup oui c'est un peu
ça ou de recevoir au foot ou des choses
comme ça c'est un petit plus de recevoir
au foot jeunes à la tête et tu préfères
jeu la maison qu'un déplacement en photo
ah oui tu veux dire de recevoir
réjouissant fait deux je pensais que tu
parlais du fait d'avoir le ballon au
début du district ou pas non mais par un
outil je pense aussi au foot j'ai vu des
stats mais je suis quasi sûr qu'ils ont
c'est évident que vaut mieux commencer
une séance de tirs au but tirant se
vouent toujours bas tu fous là pression
sur l'adversaire
toi tu raques ses fins et chiffre
atteint pm10 mais c'est pas si grave
l'autre at il a perdu le match
non mais c'est toujours le cas et c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est un peu ce
type davantage ses sens quand tu as vu
des titans autour du tout l'équipe qui
tire en deuxième allait gagner
évidemment mais un gain d'un peu mieux
de commencer une petite pression que
c'était un petit peu comme servir en
premier au tennis wii qui fait la course
en tête c'est génial
l'un devant et c'est un truc joly c'est
qu'il y ait procès 6 2 le français 6 tu
fais des cinq mais c'est joli il faut
défendre une mutation qui les processus
il faut projet de loi non mais j'ai vu
que prévu mais juste j'ai vu le premier
truc de base
j'aime et je te trouve un peu inquiet
mais ça va la grille tout net c'est
servir à lancer non ça va je préfère les
noirs quand même ce pion à moi je
préfère les blancs lamanda incroyable la
ville d'agde aph
vincent rey du coup ça c'est pas bon
pour arnaud da parce que et ont dû mener
4-1 j'aime pas dit la dame en un coup
bon on en parle nous de la paix d'un
troupeau
c'est une des pires variantes que tu
puisse jouer avec les noirs mais je sais
qu'il ya un plan très clair avec les
blancs on va voir ce qu'il va pas jouer
ça comme un chrono de chevaux qui
donneront une idée
bon c'est que non mais je pense qu'il a
fait ça juste mais il a mis combien
temps je lis ici à minsk une seconde 9
alors moi je vous entends avec g3 fou
j'ai deux personnes mais qui fait ok
mais même dans ce lapse d'habitude en
fait les n'auront pas mon dessin qui
font des six j'ai trois fous les dockers
de rock et bep cap des 5 hip hop mais
bon je veux faire un dans ces structures
là que j'ai déjà eu fait pareil en fait
jugé 3 2 qui a valu à eux deux pkp et ça
en fait je fais la même chose d'autre en
force un truc mais je déteste cette
variante avec les normes même si j'ai un
petit peu analysé femme parce que krikor
la jouer et c'est pas si mauvais mais là
je déteste la manière de traiter une
guérite uk j'adore la manière de traiter
de tout ce qui peut y avoir du cavalier
f4 même qui vient un moment donné tu
vois il cavaliere 4 pour chasser le fou
je sais pas exactement évidemment c'est
non mais les noirs sont dans la partie
c'est pas c'est pas ce pas ça le
problème et pas tellement de bonnes
manières de répondre à cette provoc spli
que le tube de l'intrus passé notamment
des 5 1 le coup que tu joues toi tiens
mon avis le meilleur 4 qui est sympa
aussi lui des cinq sens
c'est pas mal c'est ça va quoi ça après
coup j'ai cinq avaya cisco g5 des cinq
yalla vas rentrer aussi ceux ci des deux
parties mieux c'est aussi sous des cinq
ans fait mais mieux des cinq que si ce
que si ça offre taduc à l'idée de ou des
petites variantes comme ça qui peut être
pénible mais mais j'ai six mais c'est
pas si mal réputé
j'ai jamais compris parce que j'ai
trouvé dans la base même si leur a joué
ça en partie longue g6 au 2o devrait
quand même cavalier f4 en fait je
pensais candidats et surtout prend qu on
prend le roi c'est peut-être un peu la
gueule tu auras des ruptures peut-être
un jour 5 juste attend donc avec quatre
pages web
non mais ça doit aller en fait pour gi
joe pajer si ça égalise aussi si tu
joues bien mais c'est moins simple que
d'autres moyens
après c'est peut-être moins simple pour
des idiots comme nous quoi non mais ok
mais c'est comme la diffusion avec vlad
avec le
le moscou la 2d milian oui en fait ça va
mais tu dois tout souvenir avec pourquoi
faire ça alors tu peux non mais alors il
a par ok si la dame prend g6 et donc il
va aller se cache langer 7 pour par le
ressentent là est ok sans se prendre ça
donc c'est plus lent mais au moins une
heure à croire c'est plus lent au moins
c'est à une plongée 620 quoi ah oui
c'est mieux de te lance le parc de 6
ouais c'est génial en fait pour résumer
tu as pensé quoi bein non mais ok ce
n'était pas contente de les rockets en
trois jours
tu as raison c'est d'avoir dit ça va
j'ai rien contre un bon juge coincé ça a
fait rire bon la tête f 3 et 4 pour les
blancs ouais franchement je ne pas
tellement parce que je pensais qu'ils
avaient joué un grand rôle
du coup en fait perso je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire frire et 7 grand roque et
tu vois à temps il ya les canards qui te
dit que tu as pas héberger de twitch
cleastream je vais faire maintenant
j'ai appris entre une chose d'une autre
espèce pas très grave non plus
c'est pour ça qu'avant les gens savent
que le speech assez là dessus mais c'est
vrai que voir leurs effets stream c'est
un bon réflexe mais tu vois des fois ça
réflexe c'est faut vraiment avoir le
réflexe vitrine point fr du coup s'est
battue c'est toujours parce que des fois
le hausse automatique marche pas je sais
pas comment ça fonctionne ce truc là
donc j'ai été déconnecté comme d'hab
rouge était inactif pendant une heure
donc fou ces sept mois à préparer du fou
ou six les clés noires elle m'a fort le
faire un jour ce qu'elles font en fait
t'as pas trop de casse g4 tu vas te
prendrais froide façon je suis un peu
déçu que grisou qui est pas bien bien
bien répondu à cette ouverture dont
pourtant je suis un spécialiste émérite
quoi donc quoi ça prouve que quand vous
jouez au vrai échec tout de suite infâme
plus dur plusieurs plusieurs pour pour
tout le monde les vrais des chèques sont
quand même un problème infâme
voilà déjà vu plus d'une fois mais bon
là je pense que ce soit par
méconnaissance des vrais et shine je
pense que le gritche ou qui est quand
même bon marché a touché 4 donc soit tu
votes pour f5 qui perd pas mal ce que tu
casses et tu provoques 5 es tu veux
faire flouer six mois je suis réfugié 4
parce que j'ai envie de te contredire
non mais c'est bien aussi les 4/5 d'un
poney structures scolaires et puis on
prend vous prendrez hyper heureux
d'autres trouvent à jouer en europe
reprendre les mots emplis surf un fil
isolé mais ils vont plutôt poussé et en
ferez vous au 6 mai c'est des choix
efficaces blanche qui a serait chiant
foulée 3 en plus à 4,5 h5 comble objets
4 lundi dans la capitale tout en fait
restée floue g4 un point fort griffon
d'or je suis gryffondor moi je sais pas
ce que je suis je me regardais les
potins mais je connais que gryffondor du
coup j'aurais du mal à être quelqu'un
d'autre mais c'est moi pas mais c'est
pas une école deux fois ci je suis marin
gamins dans le train une fois ce qui
gère également facile en face de moi
dans un dans un train faillite avec sa
petite soeur mais ces petits avaient ils
avaient genre touchez pas moi peut-être
14 et 12 ans quelque chose comme ça tu
vas où
mais bon ils sont assis et puis y'a
quelqu'un qui
dams d'avoir jeu pendant une
cinquantaine d'années qui vient et qui
leur dit c'est ma place
on va du coup les deux gamins ils
partent et qui revient d'un car ford
après et ils sont hyper gêné quoi mais
ils disent bah écoutez vous êtes dans la
mauvaise voiture quoi à la fin et ninon
bas du gamin et dc quoi du coup là elle
regarde et alia excusez moi quoi et moi
j'étais assis en face jeudi d'un point
pour que je fais toi rester borderie
c'est très très heureux de ces deux là
quoi être très confiant mais comme
c'étaient des gamins elle avait
forcément raison qu'on va dégager enfin
voit les gamins ils étaient vraiment
très gênée d'avoir raison c'est
fantastique
bah oui enfin je suis plus frais dans la
voiture et cela sur je ne sais pas lire
mais est ce que on est si heureux dans
ce four g4 en fait il vient de le faire
sauter en suisse si je peux être à youku
saturé moi je vais échanger contre un
car est peut-être que je viens de
prendre douze heures il est sympa il va
se caler sur trois est allé taper des
cinq regards échangés
c'était peut-être pas terrible de
c'était peut-être pas terrible
effectivement fab je te rejoins
le moment même le point mais fond d'or
ben là je ferai tout reprend ces trois
femmes mais mettons qu'on soit tu fais
quoi pour prendre la merde bah du coup
tu fasses fillon prend effet refuse de
faire ses quatre occasions
c'est génial que les analyser mais qui
essaient juste de s'arrêter car des
abrutis comme ceux en plastique
oui on va face en france on a le temps
de le prendre on ne va pas s'envoler
natale bien dire ça mais c'est important
ouais mais bon le jour où tu vas te
retrouver face à un joueur qui te fait
pions volant la vache lehman mais je
pensais que doit s'envoler
tu prends la gueule quand même sillon
volant qui ont volant tu vas y à merde
je connaissais pas la règle mais glavas
torero nettoyer la théorie on va écouter
monsieur libye jet ski vous avez dit pas
en faisant le tour ne va pas s'envoler
mais bon restons vendeurs ils vous très
très loin tu vas tu fais un petit peut
être contré puis là le mec va te
rappeler que fait des prises en passant
des traditions très bizarre il va
atterrir voilà j'ai un plan maroc et
l'entrée de ramener le roi en f2 et de
fer g3 comme ça on se prend pas du faux
x3 ou du fou je sais pas quoi on s'en
fout quoi passe très bien il aurait
fermé après on va s'occuper de la dame
mon fils boulot pour ce drame et en c1
et machin hormis que duda large and mail
à 20 ans duda moi je rappelle de di dou
da maintenant depuis là mais ça en fait
ça ne m'inquiète un peu
si tu le saches quatre espaces assez
inquiétant n'est peut-être qu'un jour il
va t'emmener alors cet intrus qui
peut-être maintenant justement ma maman
damas est il faut faire du bouchon à
dire d'avoir du g3 et que le faut les
passer en revue leur web de hockey le
défense après faire j'ai trop mal mais
bon moi enfin le truc c'est que de base
en a bien voulu le laisser sont plongés
quatre ont surtout pas faire dame ces
deux éléments français 8
quelle foule in the great soutenons
ouais mais là pour bâtir la page mais
pour sa santé
si votre se plante cependant pour mieux
oui et non ça reste une fouine bloqué
pour l'instant c'est toujours en
maîtrise pour les blancs non mais c'est
du caca pour les noirs n'en donne un
coup de main de jean marc marti fat ont
fourbi les élagueurs bafa toutes les
pièces dans la gueule mais bon il en
vient alors à temps et à combien
d'heures de jeu il ya déjà une heure de
jeu fab est mort quatre 1h04 de jeu le
savons c'est écrit il progresse duda
mois mais balla gaye soldats sont trop
longs trop de soucis est-ce que tu auras
envie de dire sans trop sourciller le
paris nice ou cynique sur scène en tête
d'ameneh raja l'étudiant mais bon les
pompes à 4 mai du fait qu'une micro
manas par les eaux ces dames à 600 fou
si on revient d'un briquet à l'attrait
du poussin et b3 j'aurais pas fait par
principe mais en fait sa rentrée il a
réfléchi mais en plus trois comme monter
à l'assaut aussi a besoin dont ces huit
maintenant six heures et ça donne envie
mais ça c'est pas moi c'est génial si je
sais pas il faisait zéro menace que
c'est au dessus
en fait je peux pas vraiment la surf ou
presque a trait au g3 man ray mais bon
il va y avoir prise pris 0,8 du fait
d'armes aussi baignade un problème c'est
quand même sacrément dans la merde mais
m'attend de là
bon très mauvaise partie du match ou nas
a commencé au l'ouverture en fait le
deuxième deuxième coup et ses vins ouais
mais bon il était face à mon ouverture
donc du coup automatiquement une
ouverture de champion et on a senti que
tu as on l'a senti en difficulté face à
cette fantastique trompe austin mois
mais n'ignore était très heureux quand
on profite meilleure ouverture du monde
contre cavaliers fils après des 4 n'est
ce pas femmes l'exacte exact les compos
de liverpool paris qca est un rituel qui
est un maïs coiffe un fou c'est pareil
alors est ce que ça marche un truc mais
là je veux tellement vite que j'aurais
te dire wind par un point de confiance
car s'il connaissait c'était ma tu sais
pas quoi lasser des quatre partis quatre
fois qu'ils le jugeaient 4 m il mérite
vraiment de mener au score mais ça s'est
aggravé et contre ef quatre auteurs
avaient tout de suite dès qu'il a pu
fouiller 4 pas fou je t'interdis quoi
donc c'est quand même au dessus de tout
l'armée y est dans l'yonne également
veut-il faire 100% de gvt et 4 c'est
génial
du coup on pourrait approuver le no fake
après en mettant ses parties les unes
après les autres en mettant un logis 4
en évidence toujours important de faire
le no fake 1
- c'est parfois aussi celui de j 6 ouais
bon pointu c'est à dire qu'il va pas
perdre la pièce direct cas peut-être
perdre au plus haut niveau atteint au
roi pareil au sens des affaires c'est 80
kills et 3 millions sera menée voix à
ceux là vont en fait je sais pas quelle
poisse est si fort comme ça tu sais
contre-attaquer tous avec les blancs tg4
donc quelque part tu es plus dans
l'esprit on te félicite continent ça
mais je ferai mon bac j'ai remarqué ça
j'aurais pas du tout envie de jouer ça
l'a vraiment je travaille ici et
ailleurs alger le pion à ses fins c'est
horrible enfin h2 attaqué alors soin de
faire tranche de leur projet si ce soir
dans 2h comme kavala 10 pour ouvrir
encore plus sa colonne h je comprends
qu'un rituel c'est clairement serpentard
à isserpent tard c'est un autre beau
brad du futur qui tombe chat était dans
le truck d'escrimé personne te répondra
du coup tout un peu c'est un peu ça tout
est inclus dans le futur mais on propose
d'arrêt cet échec
trois des huit à catania brager et tu
vas te faire ouvrir ce merdier popote
djamel basso viande et 1166 apparemment
maestria des six as et les fait gris
tout bon pour ça que moi je vais tout
pas trop intéressé on fait tout ça va
attendons toute la sphère dame g2 ouais
mais alors je vais arriver maintenant je
voulais faire vous prendre quatre à
utiliser de faire flouer cinq échecs en
finale mais que fait-on g8 j'ai le temps
ok torah je pense bien joué l'homme
prend h d'euros f1 et ouais mais bon ça
m'était mal on est d'accord mais
d'ancrage de f1 tourache et 8.4 on voit
même tu as peut-être g7 qui va chanter
c'est qu'on peut être fou j'ai 5 mai m
ok otura chute directe
pour hf 8 direct pourquoi pas
bah écoute sur ça je fais peut-être tout
reprend 1,4 je sacrifie tout et je joue
cette finale ouais sur le mais bon je
rage projet est vrai mais lui faire
payer ses trois cahiers déception by
cette emprise américaine allait pas
avoir cette finale game en coiffant tu
as âge ou non n'est peut-être pas mal
non plus matière bref un tempo ne
réfléchit pas à sacha allait peut-être
faire rage et non mais attends tu peux
faire rager de aussi au moins tu menaces
peut-être un peu plus tôt fab ouais je
suis là je sais pas en fait je pense
qu'on fait roi g2 et on veut faire va
surtout réfute vous prendre 4 3 3 j'ai
mis un petit cas pas dans le chatt quoi
c'est toi plaisent
bon alors je joue quoi du fermage et
deux avions de chasse - calais bon
j'étais obligé de réagir à ton cas pas
quoi ça serait génial on arrête de
commenter on n'est que sur le chat room
écrit dans le jazz pris dans une chute
comme des abrutis quoi battant je fais
d'ailleurs là il ya des cartes matches
de la 10e trou lataillade partie de la
fédé française ont pillé des trous
qu'apparaît j'écris commentaire sur le
sujet
mais là au moins c'est pédagogique est
bon quand il ya de l'enjeu dans son
match
ouais mais du coup est roi g2g 2
pourquoi pas ouais moi je les deux mais
ok bon droit g2 qui peut me parlait tout
reprendre quatre femmes et couples va
parler c'est écrit c'est vérifiable
j'ai écrit dans le chat et la fois h 2
qui tombe à la fin peut-être peut-être
pas bafa bon échauffourées cinq échecs
des gages qui ces trois ça y est
l'esprit ça y'est fab l'esprit s'est
emparé de great showcase et trois années
boum un petit peu les plombs de bessat
tout bref c'est du gagne-petit ça tue ah
ouais mais là on est même qu'ici t3 c6
on fait quoi vous accueille à trois
voies la caricature il faut faire je
pense j'ai l'impression d'avoir d'être
des dettes sur une arena d'avoir d'avoir
en face de moi [ __ ] fire meilleur pire
meilleurs ou meilleur je respecte plus
tôt m ils échangent des pièces ouais
ouais c'est vrai qu'elles sont vraies
mais bon je respecte plus quand même non
mais là s'il va se passer si tu peux
faire c'est toi le prochain coup tu tues
tu vas faire et d échange d'espèces des
cinq à bout mais les fiancés de la merde
fab four h1 voie légale
je veux toi je trouverai je vois musique
c'est sûr fois fiat est empreint d'un
futon perdre un fric est peut-être fait
cai sekkat échec fosse est une structure
20 aussi dingue et je viens réussisse
ses barrages mais bon même fossatois lui
tout peut être mais tellement d'années
fab chez moi j'ai peur de te sentir
glisser vers le côté obscur de la force
quoi non mais c'est pas si mauvais faut
faire fouquereau 600 photos après qu'ils
aient 4e set
et que faire tout rage suite aussi
auprès du roi c'est cette web du projet
6 il prend un g5 sur cette voie les
sages de sion là
ils ont cherché une fouine reekoye dans
la position il est là quoi peut-être fou
des deux aussi des foulées quatre échecs
à la lame et tant de temps pour jouer
mes coups quoi moi j'ai deux j'ai joué
du tempo là encore une itt de perdu et
fos est allée elle fausse interdit à
peut-être tous mes tours 8 francs j'ai 6
ans le suspect balle et sasha
elle est franche des six tours j'ai huit
victoires de suite en page 2 mais aller
mais tu te mets mal autant là pour voir
des trucs avec fabre voix tempo là
qu'est ce que c'est ce qui se passe là
bas en fait il joue moins bien que nous
non mais vlad il aurait dit il n'y avait
rien à voir dans cette position là il
n'y avait rien à voir des gens de chasse
sont énervés quand il écrit fables
contes a nié par les ventes des changes
moche quoi faut que tu fasse gaffe si si
si je te vois faire une échange de la
star ou un truc comme ça je ne veux pas
de calais vont pas une échange de
n'importe quoi en fait mais change là ça
vraiment fab je le sais pas je ne
supporterais pas qua non est ce que le
prénom de gueux toutes ses stations
alexandre barrette séparer de ses
alexandrins dents mais bon c'est illégal
à sache à quoi sert ce gentil répondre
au tchad son chat ils savent peut-être
cavagnoud 5 tout comme moins fatigués
c'est frustrant coiffe avons été on
était bien on était on était dans le
game quoi je suis déçu bongo devait se
battre il va tomber sur mon projet 3,3
et le remonter
qu'est ce qu'il a mal joué on trouve
en russe alexandre alexandrov
bon il ya le lokomotiv moscou ce que
c'est le club de carpaccio non mais j'ai
un copain qui est pour le coup ils sont
1 0 à gaza il vous est très énervé trop
copains ouais il te dis toujours mon
coeur est vert puisque c'est vers aussi
je pense qu'il est pour sainté en france
il est pour les verts de partout patrick
duvert savoure mon sens et vert est donc
arrivée va tout et verts avait écrit
quoi c'est ce que tu as remarqué qu'il
n'y a pas du tout 2 nuls quoi dans ce
match là ça nous intéresse
je crois que dès qu'ils ont un avantage
tarder à gagner quoi c'est incroyable
s'ils savent pas défendre bien ce que je
disais quoi match de piètre qualité
non mais c'est sympa et 4,3 ça bouge où
je viens vers l'avant 4-3-3 quoi jeu
vers l'avant
fait non mais c'est pas esclave des
changes quoi hockey qui l'on voit on est
content ces deux spectacles et poussé
deux a des cheveux toujours ça peut-être
tous avant de faire un échange et on
fout cherchez la femme sa part le
rapport juste les rucistes août ans a
battu 3-1 france était toujours cherché
la fin même grille chromée déjà dit
cherchez la femme pourquoi on se bat ça
vient de douze chaises tous oui nous
sommes un livre où vas tu as douche elle
a dû couler mais carrément donné il
fallait il essaye de parler français et
ma faim et il cherchait la femme voyez
les choses quoi ce truc qui se dira quoi
ici ça et je ne mange pas six jours du
coup les roosters télécharger tous ces
deux phrases là je ne mange pas six
jours on a dit plein de fois leur
énergie non mais bon comme c'est écrit
comme ça ils comprennent pas qu'on dise
qu'on dit je ne mange pas depuis six
jours on a voulu te dis je ne mange pas
six jours et cherchez la femme
je voulais que tu vois tu es là tu vas
tu vas tu bois ou bottes avec flash
battu les français ou les trésoreries
cherchez la femme et fille fin fond d'un
homme qui je ne mange pas six jours et
puis vint après ça la discussion reprend
son
va-t-il is beaucoup les russes cole est
beaucoup plus calme
c'est comme si moi en fait je conseille
cité des romans de chez paquin ah ça oui
mais d'accord mais fameux c'est en
classe mais même moi tu vois je te sors
des stations de des misérables ou quoi
fanny qua non milices beaucoup plus
jeunes ont évidemment ils sont plus
cultivés
heureusement d'ailleurs
heureusement mais s'appelle doivent
faire attention la dame assise bien
jouer sinon ça ne sait si ce côté noir
côté blanc et sa surcharge et le pion g7
est normal préparer des cinq je pense
jamais arrivera enfin après bombe le
biais de ses cavaliers bien f5 qui
regardent dans le droit donc si tu n'y
as pas du sky projet cette fable aux
jeux pour enfants braquer 5g et prend
puis on prend well done me donne des
sages a perdu une pièce c'est vrai
j'avais envie femmes afin pardonne après
quoi kallos à tous mais pourquoi but de
monaco prendre but de monaco
incroyable très heureux incroyable et
des modèles de nico et la quiétude de
grandir quand plus grande scierie qui
est à 3 l'aisne il arrive direct on va
forcément en face quand même si
l'atletico madrid s'est passé pas quand
ou amiens crois donc beaucoup plus
facile mais bon enfin pf saint calais on
se bat on envoie à tour 8es chez part on
sacrifie à les femmes d'alger 3 d'un
match 4 prises en six manches ou dans
l'esprit mais ok il va il veut il veut
défendre sa gretsch bien que saddam
aussi s'il défend sur le côté donc tu
veux être le cas y en a huit ou un truc
comme ça elle était là quand même
effectué huit ex card et auquel tu étais
quand même mieux que les blancs c'est à
dire rien à dire mais venté pas mal non
plus avec les noirs si facilement
en fait ce que les noirs et - fermez là
c'est juste impossible on a atteint 37
matin il se met locales et angers 8 frg
6 pour dégager mais là ils vont pas pour
tout faire voilà donc il fait qu'il
rêvait à 8 mais ça n'intéresse pas trop
donc peut-être quatre effectivement
intéressant merci femmes en tout cas pas
de jesse tu feras cahier prend 1,6 assez
jolie soeur
merci frappe c'est que ça me fait plaise
quand tu quand tu qu'on vous sentez vous
comme un partant on peut enfin ça c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous mais pour
se dire beaucoup
c'est ça et le quai de comprendre au
pied du fou normal mais peut-être de la
tour spam je parraine la tour plutôt
fabre après tout à coulisser est fou des
deux lots de grand et fin bon vous vous
prendre de la tour en un tout nouvel
endroit quoi comme dans une vidéo de
garicoix mais du vrai garicoix pas le
garric on a vu pour le showdown quoi je
ne sais plus ce qu'il dit quoi c'est un
faux gary trouvé ça très normal de
perdre contre topalov qu'est ce que
c'est que ça j'étais très énervé je suis
content que j'étais pas le seul est
réservée rencontré un copain qui lui
aussi ne comprend rien pas même joie des
gens sur sur internet qui gueulent
convenu pas d'aidé il ne sait pas bien
de devenir cas c'est pas les gens de
l'âge pour vingt mille balles du bâlois
après les retards ce qu'il veut s'amuser
ça serait soit pas traité de joueur
magnifique il était mais ça fait de la
peine oui voir des conneries comme ça
non mais en fait tu toi si tu fais ça tu
dois parvenir pour un match comme ça tu
dois aller jouer un tournoi tranquille
et en mode jeu fin tu as doit pas faire
leur médecin je suis retraité je joue un
jouet au punk et pensions même super
retransmis en fait non non non mais oui
bon ça l'art était forcément du coup
mais je veux dire oui c'est comme les
mecs au foot qui vont jouer en 1 2
finale carrière car pires il faisait ça
à la fin donc il y avait autour de 40
ans tenait à les jouer
et tu seras par les premières tam et tu
as juste pour le délire ou enfin tu vois
c'est plus qu'on prend c'est organiser
un match genre tu as 20 et te dise pas
le retour mais c'est un semi retour
quand même fait tu as cueillir ouais pas
vraiment faim c'est juste un match
exhibition à une fois par an là où tu
dire qu'ils ont pu sauver les joueurs
match caritatif aussi dans ces cas là un
peu comme les joueurs de foot ça se
trouve il nous a pas pris les armes il
se lance et rien fait donc les bombes et
fabrice il avait donné je pense qu'il
aurait dit précédemment tour h4 et j'ai
six dames j'ai cinq ans mais ok ce sont
là ça sent le chaos latent des trucs
comme ça
dois-je 4 c'est très intéressant
ac on peut aussi préparé notre coup
vraiment ok il me charge issus également
sa cruauté soissons 1h 50 at il veut
faire justice aux cochons m inquiète
tourache 4g ici je fais d'am-dam g5 et
je comprends pas comment tu défends fait
honnêtement j'aurais peut-être un truc
hein ce que je peux faire 2006 ouais je
fais damage six échecs et frères juifs
au feu sous les yeux de son fils ouais
je sais pas cela comme un jeu rémy avait
forcément un truc surtout h cartes qu'on
n'a pas
tadam jesse surtout h4 oui beaucoup
mais oui je déconne pas mal aussi et oui
pourquoi
mais bon après pour le coup oui pour que
ce sport est le truc c'est évidemment la
retraite depuis 13 ans quand même donc
gci perdu en fin mai mais nous aussi on
joue pas depuis depuis six mois tu
reviens komm savent au ralenti depuis le
même
alors moi non mais moi même en vont tous
les jours je le cerveau ralentit mais ça
après c'est perso non mais c'est juste
que là on tue quand tu pratiques plus
quelque chose pendant mes mais ça fait
juste
ouais t'as pas envie de voir un tel
monstre mal joué mais en fait c'est un
peut citer enfin si tu avais quitté un
lion et puis tu te retrouves avec avec
un chat quoi mais c'est déjà bien chaud
quoi mais bon ça c'est très bien même
mais bon oui c'est un lieu où 5
à écouter ce qu'on peut le prendre il
veut faire il veut faire pouvez faire
tout revin et oui l'auteur 2006 parce
que nous comptons reprendre vie c'est ce
qu'on va voir d'air calédonie pièce
obligé est ok maintenant donc qu'elle
découvre l'art est-il une enquête aussi
failli fait pas de découvertes direct
mais il se place qui attaquent h5 je
peux tomber le chaos et attaquent les
obsèques on va voir en fait quand on
fait d'alger 5
cherchez la femme
on les dit tellement de fois ce truc est
déjà chaud fait un peu gêné quoi puisque
les gens te disent ah ils sont heureux
tant les barrios un bon ça veut rien
dire mais enfin je sais pas c'était un
peu de peine de leur dire la phrase que
tu avais un peu que les enfants en train
que de peut trouver bien aux tno ou
stone c'était génial si ça rentre mes
gars il s'est tellement heureux du truc
de gryffondor coiffage est très très
heureux non mesdames g5 ça c'est ça va
quoi ça va pas trop mais un peu vache
l'arrêt du parc et f6 enfin tu te
défends quoi c'est ça il faut ne pas se
disent mais c'est dommage qu'ils perdent
on ouvrait longtemps à tuer en fait non
mais c'est un peu c'est un peu triste
route retrait quoi c'te tri nous
attriste pareillement verlanger salif à
faire rejeter ce week-end à bloquer mais
d'alger 5 et 15 matchs 4 ou madame g si
tu peux et ie 7 et enfin que ces vingt
sept et pour franck et f6 et ouais mais
d'accord mais il cherche mieux mais bon
il fait des quatre copains marocaine
mais mon cou était meilleur que le sien
je suis le dessus wal fadjri ce matin
entre non non mais il sait pas paroisse
et frites damas huit voitures et
piccinini suva c'est quoi ça arrive on
va tu calcules un truc tu as vu un truc
je vois que ça va pas ça t'énerve et tu
paniques et
bonne écoute
heureusement que vlad n'est pas là parce
que là il ya 4,4 je pense que ce serait
un flot des insultes envers guy tube non
mais c'est très c'est très énervant quoi
alors monsieur pessoa qui insiste
coécrit blum duda le mojo monsieur
pessoa écoute je ne sais pas quoi te
dire pour les gens qui suivent le foot
alors ça se passe comment j'allais leur
couchette dit nous alors je vois que je
suis en train de regarder la juste sur
eurosport - 10 h 00 je sais mais vous
voyez déjà eu quatre actions pour
liverpool et une pour paris apparemment
mais possession paris je me laissais
tâte aussi aller la possession tu sais
oui oui oui on s'en fout ouais bon
écoute on verra non mais bon ok il est
chiant que ça peut être ben oui son
soutien avec leur petrov je ne comprends
pas pourquoi ils y apparaissent
pourquoi n'at-on pas de préparation sur
la petrov doit-on gens risquent eux est
ce que le second temps a fait son boulot
tiens franquart aigles vlad la très
énervé quoi est-ce que great yoox et
joue aux échecs quoi au final c'est un
peu la question qu'on est en train de se
poser ou doit-il arrêter ce jeu qui
n'est pas fait pour lui des plaques qui
nous manquait ce que signifient les
segments donc j'imagine tu parles qu'il
a il ya trois segments dans ce match
en gros en fait c'est qu'il joue un
match tous dans la même soirée
mais à trois cadence différentes donc là
il joue en 5 minutes au début de la
partie après une seconde fois en trois
minutes et après avec une minute chacun
vont de plus en plus vite et c'est ça
que j'appelle des segments vois tu pas
que ça que tu veux tu peux appeler ça
des tiers temps si tu veux ouais les
tiers-temps ne sont pas des guides pour
le coup en fait vu qu'il veut que je
joue au top pour autant de parties dans
chaque cadence du coup les partis en
cellule dur pendant une heure et demie
il ya après 3,8 pour une heure peut-être
est ramené de but deux minutes quand a
tout résumé
petit à petit je me fais quoi elle a
failli pas content quoi qu'on se plaigne
de 10 niveaux de gris turc
mais bon malheureusement tu as in situ
et on est sensé commenter le match en
fait justement vu qu'on est sensé quel
sens et ça c'est moi qui chez votre
sport le togolais c'est plus de moi ba
est donc à ce que tu as vu pour faire de
ce qu'on veut du coup un agenda qui
avait pris un air tran ba tu prends
comme 9,6
ça va aller oui sinon c'est vrai que tu
perd une place mais lassana non mais
écoutez
est-ce que c'est duda qui joue si bien
est ce que fais tu vois je me demandais
ce que ces grilles chucky et carrier
kings qui ont mal joué non maîtrise de
la période
mais va que c'est peut-être un diesel
aussi les deux pris à partie tu te dis
ça va être une boucherie le match
puisque vous vivez 2 0 mais à ces
massacres ans et après il ya la
troisième où déjà il aurait il été très
bien getxo qu'il a perdu on a six années
que j'écarte mais après tu vois il a
fait une seule trompe enfin il ya un peu
de tout mais je dois quand même si les
vingt-sept qui garantit les jeunes et ça
tourne vite dans sa tête ailleurs parce
que premier match j'ai mis ça sur le
compte d'un carnet qui n'en n'est forme
mais le truc c'est que enfin c'est ce
que c'est
en fait j'ai pas vu le match là mais le
truc c'est qu'est ce que tu peux
surprendre deux fois des joueurs d'un
tel niveau fin tu vois
c'est ça me fait penser un peu d'un
retour au tennis au début le mec un peu
comme cecchinato quoi il élimine un mec
de mecs 3 mai qu'il éliminerait les
mines great chioukhs et tout ça fatigue
pas gris tout élimine la du coup plutôt
djoko ah bon tu te dis le mec
cette dame e3 juste ouais je recruterai
d'abord l'égalisation de l'atletico ils
sont athlétiques du cou qui sont grande
digue costa bon
après douze ans il passe à la télé aussi
du coup le seul motif life for ça vous
aurait été sympa ça fait déjà 10
d'autrefois mais les polonais rare il va
parce que ça c'est une bonne chaîne
sportive je passe c'est un équipement
d'un business sport eurosport ben je
sais pas trop ce que je crois c'est une
chaîne de sport non câblées donc j'en
parle a dit un truc pour ma polyvalence
peut-être de sport quelque chose comme
ça ou sportive sport 1 c'est peut-être
l'équipe 21 ouais enfin en tout cas du
coup comparaît ce speech assez
l'importance de la compétition et machin
c'est quand même la seule compétition
d'échecs qui passe à la télé
or deux fils qu apparemment ça passe à
la télé mais ces remarques s'était passé
sur canal + sport en france le grand
james sur paris les personnes qui
regardent mais ça c'est un autre c'est
un autre débat
un but non avoué de liverpool à
sturridge à ses riches
du coup il est heureux moi non
historique reste je pense de couvrir ses
dévots raison bon alors la grille tout
au moins il va réussir à envoyer du h4
f4 donc que les autres c'était notre
répertoire facile en plus on va peut
être oui c'est vrai pas refaire le plus
joueur au niveau femme serait retournée
si facile
ouais tu as quatre noms plutôt pour
bloquer le cavalier est peut-être après
jouer à la cafsa et fin tu vois non m 4
très bien n'être a raison parce que tu
tombes sur 24 d'apprendre la case ou kg
6,05 tu vas peut-être même sur membres
d'acf 5
qu'est-ce que sur faut prendre soin du
tour et fin clouage et peut-être urgent
et 4 etc
et du coup du coup f4 par écoute un truc
qui me surprend dans ce match aussi
c'est que bouddha est toujours mal
autant et il a fait exactement la même
chose contre eux car yakine notre
précédente mais il s'est accéléré avec
les cadences basse et bientôt adapté du
jeu en fonction de la cadence mais c'est
juste que tu peux voir est ce qu'on fait
at 4 la fab
pas sûr pas sûr du tout mais ok faut
justifier le pion au chômage et pas trop
regarder je cuisine dont qui est flou
qui vaut pour fast aurait pourtant
facile bah écoute au désir de reprendre
à l'occaz même trucks ne savait pas trop
de succès quoi mais on voulait reprendre
quand même avec un truc sur la carte 9
heures vous voulez changer de forme en
ont déjà parlé maintes et maintes fois
en trente-trois plus plaisir plus ça
fera moins bien en fait mais je suis
content ce n'est plus mon lancer mais
moins bien ça marche mieux souvent
mais c'est vrai femmes non mais après au
cas où on pourra tenter de faire des
atur dans le master class est donc là ça
mais en fait sur youtube également moins
bien c'est mieux du coup est-ce que ont
fait tour à gien g4 voir mais sûrement
d'un match 3 il doit pas inquiéter a
tenté dans le 4-4-2 partir là bas
ok mais ça c'était peut-être ouais vous
qui êtes à trouver des façons de s'aimer
pas perdre ses 4 après bon vu qu'on
attaque la dame rue le temps mais
donc
la mairie de leucate à combler ce vide
et aux objectifs 2020 écoute je sais pas
mais je pense que tu es assez loin des
2000 encore donc beaucoup de choses à
apprendre avant arrive à 2000 va prendre
le temps pas après quel que soit le
niveau tresson quand il ya des vidéos ou
pour regarder
nous on tirait toujours un truc même le
truc objectif 17 cents
ça peut pas dire que jour tmx ont 3
c'est fini je ne regarde plus que jamais
surtout que je suis plus basé sur aller
lorus donc toi je suis pas basé sur les
trucs français en fait quand j'ai fait
mon truc
donc en fait je pense que 1700 ya pas
mal de trucs à apprendre fab encore une
façon même si tu connais les trois
quarts et opère sur votre chemin car de
deux choses regarder donc
donc ouais non mais tu peux y aller un
même même s'il fait un grand choix et
les trucs pour 2000 je pense que même si
ces 2000 même truc 1900 même site et
demi la monnaie tu peux y aller c'est
quoi alors heureusement en fait si quand
tu viens en russie tu te rends compte
que les classements fidh et en france
ils sont un peu surévalué par rapport au
classement des pays de l'est et du cou
il joue un petit peu mieux pour le même
et l'eau jusqu'à un certain niveau après
quand tu es grand maître quoi ça change
plus rien fab mais pour les joueurs
amateurs d'engins peu un lot 6 h enfin
après ces paquets sur deux russes yuko
mais de toute façon quand neuf pour
faire comprendre à ces options france du
cahier bouche des fossettes et il donne
prendre soin de sa peau ok est-ce que
kyle 6 bat g5 d'abord favet cavaliers 6
après non ok mais tu fais puis enfin si
ça je pense franchement déficit on prend
de branchies c'était pas gagné peut-être
je pense que grisou qui l'attend
peut-être penser qu'il pourrait le faire
après tu vois ok demander mieux au temps
ouais mais l'opposition
la fourchette est imminente mais moi
c'est ce que ben khedda mef cissé il va
mater on souffle un fab est ce que moi
j'étais coupé à l'intéreur reprise la
d'affilée mais moi je suis pas plus pour
nous tous que pour pour mon compatriote
ça quelle minute a dit ça fait une heure
39 et 35 cents dont je vais l'écrire sa
femme
je vais faire mon rapport je vais
prendre place et la pause donc je vois
j'ai le temps je vais prendre mon petit
alors attends je vais prendre là il est
là je montre mon agenda rejeu preuve je
prouve le no fake tâche en train de
prouver le no fake
moi je veux pas voir un peu bavard mais
enfin tu pourras voir diaw et avant je
vais faire le no fake alors à temps pour
trouver le no fake je vais mettre là
alors femmes je vais prouver le no fake
après un jeu vous montrer donc fab
alors c'était à une heure donc 01 39 30
on va essayer d'être secondes avant je
cite je ne suis
pas non je dis ça plus d'à peu près à
mener oui mais pour great chioukh fait
pour mon groupe atrya mais ça je vais
pas le match j'ai même pas besoin fou ça
je parle écrire je ferme les guinéens de
toutes façons sa taille c'est nous que
je prouve le no fake
voilà vous pouvez pas trop bien lire ce
qu'avec la mère avait peut-être inverser
mais voilà le no fake et la voix le
maître mon truc donc écoute moi j'ai
prouvé le no fake je vais peut-être
moins de la photo pour le mettre sur
stap et ventura je m'occupe pendant la
pause mais j'ai prouvé le no fake en
tout cas c'est prouvé cet écrit c'est
vérifiable peu nos petits manques et
pour liverpool
mais il écrit marqué il a fait un air
femmes
ah oui là bas c'est bien c'est mieux
c'est plus intéressant c'est plus
heureux l'appel du moc est souvent mis
en place 2 0 je sais pas c'était ma
chère qui avaient une une théorie que tu
rates un penalty tu ne gagnes pas le
match en général
donc c'est horrible c'est maintenant
presque
ouais je disais pour le vélo l'amour
bien ouais ça dépend des pays en fait en
fait qu tu joues de partout tout le
temps plutôt elodie internationalisé et
un peu comme les autres mais des fois on
fait genre surtout les russes
il joue que entre eux tous les tournois
sont pas forcément homologuer son fish
et du coup c'est pas comme en france
tout le temps à son homologué et où en
fait on fait tout un plat d'huile aux
mêmes dame même dans les galeries à des
régions tu as des pêches dans le message
paraît que c'est un peu disparu mais
quand j'étais gamin les joueurs d'île de
france c'était sûrement beaucoup mieux
classé que les joueurs ou plus et donc
pas ce côté là et deuxième truc les
russes sont souvent moins fort en
tactique que nous mais beaucoup plus
cultivé et donc ça joue aussi pour les
connaissances tout le bec qui a mis un
clip no fake je regarderai merci merci
pour le no fake double take c'est cool
de prouver les no fake donc le no fake
est prouvé il ya même le clip et bah
écoute phase aura des comptes à rendre à
la haye les bons enfin tu rigoles à 1
mais bon j'ai mis un petit machin ce
jeune homme s'est pas c'est pas moi qui
vais devoir rendre des comptes sur ce no
fake fab
je suis désolé je m'excuse 1
je m'excuse mais mais c'est comme sa
femme n'ose génial que notre sens du mot
fantastique soul au funk pareil c'est
pour ça qu'il faut suivre les life avait
sur les trucs qui se passent
il se passe toujours quelque chose sur
nos lives pas oui surtout sur les arénas
mais surtout celle de vendredi ne sais
pas pourquoi je sens qu'il y avait une
faille qui va pas falloir raté une femme
n'est ce pas mais tu donnes tu as
travaillé pour moi j'ai travaillé dans
le making of me choque ou encore où tu
ne sais pas si je vais me sentir de la
dire quand même parce qu'elle est ultra
violente mais bon ça dépend ça dépend
qui joue vendredi
et c'est vrai que c'est le vrai joue
comment ça se passe allait s'accélérer
lundi mercredi vendredi et qu'il a fait
faire les troncs à le soir ans tu vois
je souhaite jouer comme je peux pas amer
je peux pas de chance fascine la chance
à la chambre que le hasard la chose
laza je pensais pas voir la science si
comme vous dites se libérer un petit peu
ouais tout d'un coup là tu ne feras pas
un prix je te nuire et dans tous les
tournois jamais je n'abandonnerai enfin
bon c'est pas ça être insupportable mais
ça a tellement énervé en fait ce truc à
2,1 fab vue du psg non but je me dis
qu'est ce qu'en ps but de mener à oui si
je suis pas rentrer à 2-0 même temps
c'était très bien mais du ca en plus ça
va et me disais bien que c'est un bon
gars quoi bon joueur en plus il aimait
jh oui mais justement il était pris à
partie puisqu'il avait leaké un tifo de
des supporters de l'om sur twitter bon
bah du coup mon jeune frère a pris à
partie je quitte le club
bon le mec reste marque des buts on veut
plus bas mais le mec qui s'occupe du
twitter de marseille s'est fait prendre
à partie ce fantastique suis pas certain
vu ça en fait à un moment donné
il a été très heureux que rim bape en
équipe de sefrou faute faute grave
moi c'est ça lévesque il a expliqué que
bah écoutes je fais ça sur ton twitter
personnel si tu as envie mais là tu
dégages hockey en est reparti et
maintenant mon changement de cadence en
trois minutes
est ce que tu veux juste un point sur
les scores en ligue des champions mais
je suis au courant mais tu peux faire a
pour jean leccia peut-être qu'ils
suivent pas alors bruges dortmund 0 0
étoile rouge de belgrade
naples 0 0 c'est sympa avec des
champions de galatasaray lokomotiv
moscou 1 0 pour le galatasaray liverpool
psg 2 1 monaco atletico madrid 1 partout
chalk porto 0 0 2 watts et si tu n'as
pas une équipe française ce soir
personne ne peut s'asseoir à table by à
un gain de 5 ce soit un peu oui oui mais
bon je leur parle assez un but quoi bien
un seul but
ormat l'équipe française donc que
quelques pas qui peut nous parler bon
voilà ça la pression de chritian bouger
ça très bien surtout cac est en d2 dont
c'est la 6e place alors que l'énorme
hugo lloris est très bien placé en
portant sa fabian je pense est une règle
de base bon que tu meures de maîtriser
les côtés il ya en tout cas 44 210 donc
alors lui carrément c'est le sait le
code postal il représente sa vie leur
dire que c'est quelle ville 44 210 je
vais regarder sans doute qu'ils
voyageaient en premier je regarde aussi
44 210 c'est pornic
henry quinson ville de pornic saluant
tout donc c'est vers nantes par la voix
quoi du coup j'imagine qu'il doit bien
aimé cramique
j'ai failli me retenir quand même salle
à manger quand même peut-être un peu
loin 3 les fans des fois je sais pas à
quoi c'est là ça sort tout seul je sens
qu'il vaut mieux pas le dire tu vois je
me dis mais après tu vas tu tu lis quoi
je vais donc été vu ce que j'en peux
plus a dit comme un des barons le
sentais venir malgré grande si ça va
suffire
on se dira je grandsir peut-être c1
c'est un anglais en fait c'est un grand
site non mais ça le français mais aussi
grossir très bien c'est cette remise
d'invention je pense que mieux mais
pourquoi je pensais ceux des baisses que
ses grands vins c'est comme goudal je
passe tu connais la bière ou d'un
fromage
en fait c'est good el boukili goodell
les boutades la bière bonne chose ben
écoute ça sert quels intérêts goodell
fromage ail et ça c'est hollande et non
oui comme guéri donc ça nous fait pas
les faire une transition sur le match de
jeudi qu'il fera pas rentrer raté 19
heures exactement
guy à rognan donc du lourd donc fromage
hollandais contre fromage arménien a
réagi très dommage arménien le tchi tchi
tchi tchi je pense ça s'appelle le
cha-cha-cha non piétine nantes cherche à
ses chats
c'est une boisson laisser un alcool
géorgien ça j'en avais bu pour le
mariage de mathieu grenet
en réalité c'est de la grappe à
s'arracher bien ouais c'est de la grappe
à mai
eux ils friment ils appellent ça cha cha
cha cha et vous chez shields et des
arméniens très bon devant arménien
fromage arménien ouchichi uci jessains
que cinq femmes le mort par çi ouais
pourquoi pas
ben écoute cinq ans peut-être aussi ce
avec l'idf car on en faire le fou et
cavaliers cette quête des 5 3 mais
j'aime pas trop vous révélant des cas on
n'a rien vu passer des messages sur
facebook est partout quoi bon se désole
habitants voient moins de bruit t on
suggère quoi tu es non mais en fait ok
c'est justement cet allongement vibreur
parce que je faisais mais des buts de
partout où tu vas je ne voyais pas le
but de paris en fait j'ai envie d'être
au courant quand je veux un bruit qui me
titille mais là avant le président si
des messages facebook
il me prendre en cascade et diguiny
super fan je mets tout le temps en
silencieux le téléphone en fait j'en
conclus et jtp kung fu si on t'appelle
je réponds bah je vous fais bien quoi
mais c'est plus facile alors sur skype
facebook général quand tu fais des
vidéos étaient insupportables bon mais
les gagnons notre ami sacha il s'est un
peu mais ça prend un avantage de deux
points ont fait un petit break et on va
voir une fouquereau cette attaque la
tour tour f 7 ne vous s'en va et on peut
prendre b2 sûrement aller en prend b2 il
faut aussi en dessous vient en c3 cette
pizza y réfléchit bon ok peut-être qu'il
s'en fout de toi je sais pas si tu te
fous ces trois prouver s'en foutent plus
que ça mais ok c'est le rein chez pas
y'a pas devoir laisser faire revenir ce
fou quand même
bref ce qu'on veut en plus en plus
option blé pouvait être important face à
la crise on est au mieux 10 ans des
quatre façades et je n'ai rien que la
potion quelques coups bas prix bon ça
vas y je crois qu'il a bien joué la d444
en instant la d466 du coup ils veulent
aussi sur 17 c est pas question des
recettes non mais tu attaques et la
tourbe et je suis vous êtes un à cinq
verges et donne un petit zite note sympa
suire tours angers 7 bis rifle on en
revient s'éprennent de jeux sur internet
- tuera les parties quoi parce que si tu
joues en réel là tu vois rien y a pas de
retransmission
y a pas le choix pamela il est un peu
moins bien mais ça va tenir non désolé
mais revient de faire mes tripes c'est
la vie après je pensais pas sur le
mystique que la partie se joue enfin non
mais tout est rangé cette l'orage cette
femme total j2 tu proposes g3 fin mais
j'arrive peut s'en vouloir car là mais
la position avant était vêtu part
peut-être un point de me d'évaluation
sur ce coup à la cour de district
envoyez le pion mais le mec va te faire
tour des cinq affaires - le tracé filles
ont besoin qu'un match retour des
cinglés bessette
oui le déficit comme joseph 4,5 me
pousser l'autre
attends mais là il va se prendre deux
ans dames mais il a très mal nulle
oui mais voilà l'organisme mais assez
génial escaliers nous échangions
[Musique]
localement le gagner ok 5.5 au west show
mais là un peu de chances qu'à mains
pour trouver avec le message de nos
slips à nouveau le masne bon il y en a
marre des petrov arrêtez moi ce à quoi
interdisez moi cette ouverture
ouais après appris great choc qu'ils
méritent et qui méritait peut-être mieux
mais mais mais mais c'est quand même lui
qui a un peu tu vois a toujours dit
d'accrocheurs toute façon et puis ils
vont tu convertit pas tu ne dis pas tu
peux t'en prendre qu'à toi même
yaka masse impressionnante audard bien
il résiste par tous et pas ici il était
un peu plus fort dans les ouvertures un
peu mieux préparés tu vois mais c'est
normal par rapport à son âge ça viendra
ça va venir mais honnêtement moi il
m'impressionne duda tu as il
m'impressionne plus que oui
non mais oui c'est bizarre il est membre
progresse pas il est déjà assez haut
d'hier m
on attendait monts et merveilles et
qu'il a cartonné tout le monde est en
fait un 'carton' à rien parce qu'il ne
joue même pas en fait les passants à
leur table pour l'instant non il peut
pas savoir la table va s'asseoir à la
table de mitroglou meilleurs attaquants
d'europe femmes
on doit trouver un moyen fait retour des
trois jeunes tu me connais tellement
bien faire tomber 3 et voir ce qui se
passe là bas j'ai quatre de l'autre côté
qui a du coup vu que laura hélas un fake
g4 ça perd son sens mais pk meilleure
grille tout qui était très bien au score
tant qu'ils g4 à toutes les parties il
arrêter ce prêt seront bien champ qui va
le perdre ce match on peut noter ça
surtout car honnêtement je pense que là
mais tout à fait d'accord avec moi en
fait je suis dire vrai c'est vrai quand
il voulut tellement mal je note moi je
suis obligé 1
mais je reviens petit b6 qu'avec les
mains du sang ravir la même chose mais
peut-être que faire b5 sais pas non mais
je vois l'idée situe à faire d'un
matisse tour des trois tours à 3 mais
bon déjà fort à faire demain 6 octobre
et 80 la chanteuse tu fais des cinq
quand même que y'a 5
peut-être mais toute femme écoute femmes
des stress ya point s ces cinq j'allais
je te jure je peux pas prouver lui nos
facs
mais je te jure que j'allais dire vous
allez tire ses cinq équidés b5 ses 600
nous fixons aucune vraie mais on peut se
croire on se fait confiance pm depuis le
temps juste et sûr puis on prend sur
besbre en fou prend oui non mais faut
pas en prison ça sans fonds c'est ce
qu'on appelle une enfonça là
on demande c'est qui le seconde en 12
ans alors ça c'est une bonne question
fab la semitan je vends par l'étonnant
aris habitants par les terres du mouton
qui le suit de partout depuis quelques
années et mis ton c'est un bon gambade
polonais à plus de 1600 26,50 quelque
chose comme ça très sympa d'ailleurs un
plus et il joue plus trop au fait il
passe son temps que tôt qu'avec avec
duda doudou da mais non mais ça va la
pourriture que femme je reprends la
confiance je vous retire ce que tu as
dit non je retire pas mais ça va mieux
tu as lloris renage ou vrai échec il a
arrêté là ces trucs de tu vois il envoie
et donc ça tout plein au nom de quel âge
il a 20 ans
non mais c'est dangereux mais géré quand
tu t'appelles gritche ou que tu n'as pas
le droit de reculer face à duda non
c'est quand même pas mal comme il joue
de 2 à 6 2 me katz un pas qui des deux
du ku'damm des trois dames des quatre
peut-être m pour entrer en d2 fab des
quatre je te manges dame e5 pardon hein
excuse moi j'étais entre ça et le
cavalier des quatre qu'elle je pensais
pour les bulles de mots sympas c'est
peut-être même mieux que le dôme d'être
allé tu as quand même on traitait
mesdames des trois peut-être mais a mené
trois prises et près le fric b4 [ __ ]
faisait chaud poste c'est la contre
attaque
je suis pas prendre ces six quand même
ces 3 mb de maths
ok je fais peut-être pions c'est chaud
mais je le fais je vais faire cailler
des quatre qui a aidé de personnellement
mais bon il est peut-être un truc avec
les prendre à m quatre échecs dames
français karim fait de la merde aussi
mais peut-être on va la perdre c'est la
femme mais là bon ok c'est pas de chance
pas de chance à ce moment qu'est cas les
profs où pranger 5e
et surtout ou trois tours pointe de là
on est au christ en fait je sens que tu
es plus pour doute avec pourriture
non franchement que le meilleur gagne
voilà
mais l'idée plutôt sympa les cinq femmes
à l'épreuve
m.bien problème des cinq dames ces trois
dames ces deux dames à 3 aux biens
québec
oui j'ai vu ça madame détroit le tuteur
prochain pourrait peut-être ça me
paraissait pas idiot v5 soit restée que
le pion bk soit pas encore assez lente
l'a peut-être mal fait dans ce temps là
s'échauffent avant non mais c'est ce que
mon père ne tue pas sur fabre g la
flamme fab et points 2 - de khombole
salle et tour un aléa les beats lorena
vers des singes et apprendre des seins
je pense à lui je veux aller prend et
viennent la crise car bon perdant après
vont à une partie peut voir des matchs
philippe c signifie 2005
et du coup l'odeur prend le lead voir
fois du match j'en peux plus te paraît
importante vous pas laisser passer le le
trop loin d'ailleurs le changement
d'ouverture parti pour neuf d'or fab toi
tu es tranquille tu at&t pour personne
tu vis je vit tranquillement la vie
tranquille quoi celle inverse de tous
avec le foot quand je suis en super quoi
ouais moi le foot ça va tu vois je suis
pas sous pression quoi enfin quoique là
si ce soir un petit peu mais mais je
suis plus sans pression pour great chaud
que tu vois pas ce que c'est un ami quoi
donc plus sous pression à là ce soir
c'est ce point soleil mais 95 à 6 non
mais j'aime pas le scénario
oui bon ok donc direction la caisse des
cinq évidemment qui est l'objectif des
blancs dans ce genre de structure tu
sais les buts et soulage un peu plus
faible à c'est trop c'est trop de motifs
pour moi la voile c'est pas un but mais
c'est un mail d'importance totalement
sevré ling qui très content kiwi nous
adaptons nous savons nous pas plus ils
sont ils voulaient le groupe null null
null
et là il ya h4 mais qu'est-ce qui fait
le cavalier en âge cette fable j'en peux
plus non mais 20 mai au quai de ce que
ça va fab je ne peux plus c'est je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce scénario
c'est le scénario cauchemar et j'ai
l'impression que chaque partie est une
longue traversée du désert algérien qui
se travaille à vous et lyng alors en
fait non bah écoute fait hum ça ne
changera pas que la compagnie oui c'est
pas ce serait pas de contrepoids ce qui
n'a pas beaucoup et d'objets de 4,9 il
vous prend justice
afp / d'alger car tu te rendes
outsourcer si ça va tu as plein de
défense mes dessins qu'il fallait faire
évidemment l'opc 4 arrive à m'échapper
ça il concentre toi sur le bras la lie à
fouquereuil 6 directement mais fables
ont conclu monsieur pessoa unique à 1500
spectateurs mais les mecs évidemment
merci d'être 1500 je la vois la fin leur
voix mais mes bons mais mais je ne peux
pas quoi faire je peux pas faut que
j'aille tous deux gagnent aussi fin j'en
peux plus la jpp les mecs
non mais là ça va peut-être c'était du
faux projet de dames france de d1 et
tours france et 2 à la fin je pense
qu'il avait dit
femme fait quelque chose quoi mais moi
je ne peux rien faire
non mais je m'en remets toujours à toi
en fait quand ça va pas je sais que tu
me carle l'état il faut compter 2 ok bon
du coup il se passe pour un cru pas ça
existe des rallyes l'état pc2 tout ça à
mon problème si tu vas perdre 5
peut-être mais bon tout n'est pas perdu
j'imagine un échange massif jordan pro
il faut prendre des huit tours prend des
8,3 prendre le tout repenser de et toura
d1 là il a fait dans ce sens hier autant
le faire faut croire que la femme bun
peut-être et après cheveux ou m6 ou
tchouprov 5 à 6 1 6 1 la savane repris
des huit femmes je revis de bon à dire
c'est bon moyen mais je vois d'ailleurs
je souffle souffle ça vient me dit tu
connais que toi ton souffle tout ça tu
as raison ça marche tu sens le vert
rentrée se diffuse dans ton corps ont
été diffusées mais voilà bon après faut
travailler ça tous les jours c'est pas
ça suffira pas une seule fois non non on
est toujours mal mais je suis plus
diffus la race en a pas d'autres repères
8 ou venue ma foi pourquoi pas et sa
lutte est chaude
heureusement je regarde le match avec
toi on sera avec delà de la je pense que
ce serait là ce serait oui ce serait dur
à gérer qui part prendre le ch ne fait
attention c'est après ça devient trop
diffus s3c acheter aussi de se connecter
à deux est nouveau ici donc là bas mais
si bon vent à toi merci de s'abonner à
la chaîne
mais pour tous les nouveaux n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à fortiori c'est
important quoi on récupère à 5 peut-être
fable j'ai envie de le prendre ce pion à
5 ce que je sens qu'il va me poser des
problèmes après touré fuite et au québec
a été le cas 3h à achat les fab sans les
tifos quoi comme pour l'hiver et je peux
taper sur la bouteille ouais c'était
cool je sens que grands et plus pour
sasha sa méthode en sueur je pense qu'il
est revenu dans le match parce que tu as
dit que tu étais de moi quoi 3 que si
vous faites fi la qualité peut-être la
croix à 5 c'est bien c'est bien c'est
bien la fantastique
ouais ouais il fait la gueule sur la
caméra il est dégoûté il a fait un petit
mouvement de tête il en sueur donc
validé gaston boum boum
il est malheureux petits cris
d'encouragement tôt tout ça gagne puis a
sauvé quatre pouces et 5 femmes tchic
tchac alors une pièce de but ce sont
quoi qu'on fasse c'est bon oui bon ok et
touré fuite
[Musique]
mais toi tu gagnes pas dire est une arme
ok mais tu veux pas réfléchir avec une
pièce de plus sa charge aux pattes un
joueur d'échecs quand même kg quatre
femmes ont probablement il est ultra
résistant bien joué
s'est passé en corse avant première deux
hoquets bonne nuit congolais peut-être
tout reprend à saint cloud puces non
c'est une pousse son pion ce point même
de le mater mais c'est incroyable que
critiquer autant de mal à gagner ça pour
preuve la toile et c'est pas mal non
mais bon 3 5 et arte à tour tu perds ta
tour non mais moi j'ai vu en fait il ya
toujours ces deux
incroyable importe c'est n'importe quoi
2 vous avez raté pour auquel chaque
échec les chèques et euh non c'est pas
pour toi ça non je mangeais trois
sapeurs a besoin d'aucun plonger sa
tournée mais très demandés c'est dur oui
je regardais milliardaire en cours avait
clairement finalement genre en continu
non c'était un derrick ward a finit
enfin par regardons ça madame machin a
très bien joué lemaitre lui gagnent de
suez environ 600 emplois sont des
répliques exactes pour safina ma femme
on est presque tous les états dans cette
partie ouais d'aller sacha guano petrov
qua non qui doit me dois insipide bien
son ami je pense que les finales des
trucs insipides
mais fabre on est passé par
gagnants/perdants gagnant caisse et a
été gagné en trouver qu'un kit juckes
les ai vus l'autouroute à vue le foodlab
tu pouvais passer par derrière je pense
est plus simple que kiev 1-1 mais ça
marchait pas je pense je pense qu'ils
les moyens d'arrêter le machin ou tout
début avant qu'il fasse l'échec de
mètres la tour derrière et de mètres la
tour paris 8
c'est ce que je veux dire peut-être bien
suresnes le roy hill et angers 6 2 en
effet de base tu pouvais faire tour c4
il faisait chaud et vieux tubes des
tours 4 mais en fait ce n'est pas le
temps de faire ça par nature il a fait
eu 2 et machins et tour ces deux fous
des deux titulaires face je pense
qu'amélie perdez faut pas se
retrouveront ce genre truc au kef où des
cinq subtil je vous provoque ces six ans
soit qui ait pas mécontent mais ça te
prend la place du cavalier
en fait on va pas parce que le futur et
protège oui oui je veux dire ok tu as
envie de le faire un jour il est chiant
se font des sociétaires qui sont pour le
moins agréable cavaliers et sinon témoin
à tartas et c6 pression sport24 donc
c'est intéressant ce que tu fous des
cinq jolies cartes et vont partir il va
peut-être revenir en c6 ou quoi je sais
pas si c'est fantastique série d'actions
kg fait caraïbes et a6b 4 des trois
échanges officiels charges concernant m
4 peut-être et puis tour d un onze et de
faire des cinq à temps non mais ça va
fab
tu mettrais bien le cavalant de cinq
personnes
oui il est un peu mieux cette g4 en fait
le prochain g4 g5 qui menace en fait on
a compris il fallait dire ça chaque
commence à comprendre les échecs
l'échéance du vote le prendre son temps
de contact n'a pas joué un coup normal
mais tu te font faire et on trouve six
mois mais nous on se le prendrais pas
parce qu'on comprend on tue avec le g4
pour nous c'est un coup naturel c'est
une menace constante mais fait un mais
il ya un manque dans le livre de gary
quand il parle de lui donc c'est là
dessus d'eux malgré tout possesseur ses
livres bleus donc c'est moi après qui
était petit il avait raté une allée
keane yamina g4 g5 comme ça prend forme
il est parfait terrain je pense faire
ces deux et après cavaliers 5 et envoyer
des tours
rêvons pas mal de faire son son cahier
des six efforts en fait chance caire
voilà
away qui comprend pas où 400 personnes
ils ont payé est ben ça va on est tout
le temps beaucoup un les mecs
sur sur les spéciales sont a toujours du
monde sur c'est normal et là on n'a pas
de joueurs français n'y a rien donc
imagine le soir il va y avoir la carac
six mois techland ailleurs ce match je
crois que c'est le dit c'est quand tu
peux pas c'est celle que 12 vous voulez
11 autres comme toi sc octobre le sommet
en plus tu auras blog ouais c'est le 11
bayod rappelé à des vagues il sera à
fond pour maxime c'est sûr je suis
inquiet quand j'ai six mois mais bon il
y aura peut-être encore fou prend 1,3
peut-être qu'il prend la fuite il prend
aussi soin la csac allez allez petit
voilà peut-être faire un tour 8 et il
menace quand même après tu vois bien le
oui mais ça va aller mais il faut avoir
la gagne est encore faible c'est pas
fait pour bush aussi bon ok j'ai 6 ans
quand même même s'il veut prendre des
quatre peut-être on peut le laisser
prendre des cas pour bouffer g6 ça
serait déjà toute hâte d être des cinq
femmes il a un petit peu te par les
femmes fabriquent un joueur d'europe
comme les troubles ou qui peut s'asseoir
à table
non mais ça ça va et maintenant faut
retrouver un petit coup précis femmes
n'ont pas hyper précis ne crois même pas
trois matches et trois acquis des rois g
de shit le new par les fab mais qui nous
parlent ce soir
bon
fall c'est hyper important si on la
gagne 1 reprend le lead à ce moment du
match
après la partie très chaude qui vient
d'y avoir je pense qu'il peut marquer le
coup la tour est vrai aidé beaucoup
mieux parce que tes pièces un f6 des six
peuvent pas bouger
elles doivent défendre des pions
horizontalement avec lequel il s'en va
thor français s'il faut s'en va tout
reprend j'ai skié sur ces gerbes
augmentée ra que c'est une 406 les gens
ici présent c'est pas sur tout autre
chose comme vous ne trouvez pas les
chiffres n'est pas 800 mille coquet mais
fab
j'aime pas mais pour eux aussi soin au
français
ah oui y'a pas franchement quel point
est donc là quand même ça c'est gagnant
sa boîte les fous de cloud reposer les
tours et même sans les tours qui ont
sont très éloignées femmes
mais bon ok ce n'est plus de chances de
vision ces quatre c4 c5
ok mais prend ses gagne ça gagne ça je
le sais pas en fait
le truc c'est qu'il ya pas de forteresse
par contre mais ça peut vous trouvez
toujours ce même diagonale genre le pion
à vii et l'autre sur la bande des
monnaies allez tous à coulisse avec
l'euro un pape quand tu viens inversée
bien versé et quand tu reprends la
veille par là bas est juste au tempo
près ouais mais non les pions à ça fait
que ça va gagner mais il faut qu'ils
reviendront des centres je veux et
voltaire petit à petit les bons fous ces
cinq finales sera servi à rien du roi un
peu plus loin c'est épouser un an plus
tôt pyongyang
c'est un drame plier se trouvaient deux
tons que j'ai croisés car c'est bien
joué femmes
ok c'est les hools un ghetto quand il
ajoute bien avancé 5 ok hélas ces gars
là des formes en valeur mais en vérité
je sais pas où et processions purger
faut sacrifier même costume jaune non
roger ça non le v12 a aussi s'accroche a
défendu sa et continue de défendre mais
son fonds v5 hyper mal passé c'est mieux
si c'est le drame touche borden oui et
jet set et match on s'assied et louvion
fin de mi temps encore intuitif où il
fallait tout mais 1,3 à liverpool le
prendre à temps mais là je n'ai pas été
appelé sur mon appui constant je veux le
no fake je veux un anneau fabrique les
12 à il est hyper dur à battre
comment allez on est remonté à 7,6 ya
toujours pas de bulle dans cette non ce
match notre audace et j'aime beaucoup
elle a changé elle n'a pas précisé si
finalement je crois pas il ya pas eu de
but de liverpool n'a qu'est ce que est
ce qu'on me dit quoi le chat ce mode de
mon nom n'est pas eu des lieux a pas du
tout en fait
pas du tout fab mais bon ils n'ont pas
approuvé le no fake banon une faute
juste avant un but refusé en fait un
en-avant ou quoi j'avais vraiment faute
league
je veux souhaiter un sifflet maria du
monde par contre y'a pas grand monde sur
le chat on a un chat à seymour
bon ça va notes mais oui c'est vrai
qu'il n'ya pas mille quatre cents
personnes sont chaque il recommence avec
son rôle de filtre est ce que c'était un
mystique
non je pense pas peut-être que ça aurait
été pas été un mystique qui touchera
mais sur voire accru de 3,4 en fait t'as
pas très envie de ce tapage saint girons
usa 9 la tâche 5
on me dit mon toit même pas lancé très
énervé vous êtes tous cas moi j'y peux
rien enfin c'est pas moi qui suis mis un
peu vous êtes un peu mou comme du nougat
femmes aux seins nus gamou nous bien de
tenir non nougat chinois à se connaître
pour dénier aux gars de partout mais
quand même le vrai mais je sais pas et
c'est vraiment du nougat mével appelle
ça du nougat donc automatiquement ça à
l'appellation vlad quoi hein mais plein
de gens appellent longuement fait la une
en espagne chez google
elle nous l'a d'ailleurs nous gâteau un
jeu plus beaux habits en lambeaux balisé
peut-être on fait des 5 à 5 des cats
allez quoi vraiment vamos la couronne
c'est symbolique doublera à nîmes bat
bat peut-être s'est inspiré jossin je
pense pas tout blanc espagnol
bon j'ai encore été déconnecté il y en a
marre allée b 5 des cas convoi a été
hissé sans que ça fait chier c'est pas
grave on voit coiffant tu vois tu es
dans l'esprit à fond ce qui est sûr
c'est contre 12,1 moi je me ferais mais
défoncé mais ça le fait non mais bon
j'aurais aucune chanson ça c'est
insupportable
je pense et on semble aimer cap et 2007
c'est pas des charlots c'est évident et
donc c'est autre chose qu'au sénat mais
là c'est vraiment failli ces partis ne
s'imposeront pas des chaussures tu fais
comme je dirais même grille tube tu vois
il a moins de l'eau kandinsky ou quoi
mais ventes bien d'autres choses mais
non meilleur que dubaï fait partie de
faillite et à leur table quoi
ah oui bon il faudra rendre service à
leur table mais un jour sera associé à
leur table et que eux mêmes feront le
service je sais pas donc c'est pas non
mais tous équipe de pologne sera plus
forte que nous quelle équipe de france à
mon avis aux olympiades
ils paraissent comme très dangereux a
mené son fort très fort même si sur le
papier on est plus forts ils me
paraissent très dangereux parce que dave
walsh taceq bas mais ok mais dès qu on a
maxime c'est quand même une autre
histoire l'an dernier on était à maxime
où je l'appelle le dernier match ce
quasiment c'est mal c'est ce site mal
donc pourquoi ces partis pris de montrer
toutes les parties du point de vue de
gris tubes en fait on voit toujours d'un
point de vue parce que en fait je suis
un des deux joueurs mais franchement on
voit du même point de vue et c'est cool
de change et blanc et noirs et pourquoi
gris tubes pour soigner pour griot qu'en
fait tu as tué protège ou non mais
saison que tu peux essayer de tuer
obligée contractuellement
mais tout ça que moi aussi je suis je
suis côté great zschokke a naturellement
mon truc je suis du côté de paiement oui
je reste ce fastueux suivre des partis
au clic et à chaque fois tu vas tu fais
suivre voire folle haut et en bas tu le
vois tout le temps jouer donc que ça te
met du coup vers ce toujours là et en
plus gris tout comme il a plu deux lots
bailly les pays dits le prenant à lister
tu perds pas ton temps à aller chercher
web police fighter en plus aux
sarkozystes fighters et duda malgré tout
on m'a taxé catch up comme seka tubes
comme le port salut et du cou et du coup
voilà ça irrite moitié comme le port
salut
il n'est pas trop d'imagination pensions
de ceux d'autres infos n'a oui mais
moment il n'a pas de 2,3 me laisse pas
chris hughes 3000 qua non
bon mais il n'arrive pas à contrer la
[Musique]
dame prend des gamins il a du mal à
contrer quand même latron poste qui
comme une ouverture qui pose des
problèmes comment fut donc le ca oui
cette fois ci ça va mais bon écho kemper
qu'il prend décide tout l'échangé d'un
même processus pour les nuls panu mieux
ça c'est blanc veut encore un qui a été
3 mieux merkel c'est cette époque est
bizarre qu'ils peuvent kenneth pour des
deux médias - ceux-ci forçats
ça a l'air fort un peu comme le
roquefort du coup plus fort que l'europe
soit mais peut-être que ces 5 mettant
des craintes on me les donne c'est ok
peut-être ça m'a plu sur le clouage
j'espère qu'il va le voir je sais faire
que ça marche qui va le voir s'ils
savaient que si ça marche tu le vois ça
un petit peu de parler je sais pas
en protecteur des cinq aussi notre
chapitre des 5 6 4 jeudi est ce que vous
vous fait toujours cavalier us food et 4
c 5 j'aime ce que te mets là tu as été
beaucoup la tête recueil des cinq qui a
rallié match c'est bien pour eux un
[ __ ] je vais faire carayos but c'est
marrant ce que je voulais prouver qu'il
réussisse et intuitivement je n'ai pas
pourquoi on fait mais ça se sentait que
ça suppose que des fonds aussi je
ressens ce truc mais notre cerveau vois
ça j'en suis sûr non mais c'est pas que
s'ils voient concrètement tu es une
tactique c'est juste qu'il reconnaît
qu'il ya un schéma merdique demeure un
fou et le voilà peut-être fou 3 1
c'est une qualité 4 la tour d2 d4 même
poussé à fond de jeu chez tout le monde
il yad'ailleurs fief de evatt informer
la tour mais bon tu vas pas te
rectifions pas celle des cet échec il
voit vite à toute la défense qui l'a pas
justin s'est marré cette fuite n'ont
évoqué le match était très plaisant
ouais c'est plaisant et 30-0 il ya 30 01
j'ai rien à faire là c'est souvent là
tout peut arriver à un bien sûr
préférez un carnage regarde un match de
fédérer que rihanna au cinquième set et
que les gens sont contents l'âge est
sympa même s'il veut bien entre 0 voilà
c'est bon c'est fait non mais pas de
l'automne qui mène 2 set 0 tu finis et
puis voilà il est riche qui m'a l'air
non je suis 100 qui va perdre en fait
baver tous ceux qui jouent bien en mode
de vie tu mérites choqué comme le chat
illumine ce soir un désolé pour ceux qui
prennent en haute savoie
non mais c'est chaud je n'ai pas eu une
somme nulle zhouqu était bien parti ils
menaient 2-0 81 81 et puis après il y
avait 6 5 pour douze heures puis 7 6
avait choqué il se fait égaliser
voilà donc ces shows en général 12 h
paul est revenu à cécilia ne sais pas
pourquoi je veux que des petrov il est à
succion avec ça marchait bien et du coup
je me demande pourquoi ils ont ils
repartent soutiennent parce que il a
joué c'est au début du match
donc il a fait un partout mais qu'est ce
qui veut dire qu'à coller dans la
première et dans la deuxième il est
impérial wes assez classique dans ce
genre de trucs mais ce que je veux dire
c'est même s'ils gagnent celle là ces
choix bizarre de stratégie de match mata
une ouverture qui marche bien pourquoi
tu changes
et pour revenir là où tu avais des
problèmes au début que c'était enfin je
sais pas allez faut ramener le camion
rue en 2 3 g4 chasser cette dame c4
non mais pourtant sera en fête avec les
blancs faut être très dynamique et notre
position bon déjà tâtonnements mais en
plus il ya la peur de flou à long terme
c'est juste une dynamique mais aucun
problème des noirs l'eurocentre
développement néant donc ok ça et a fait
mine magino quoi donc et flo7 on les
veut pas trop 15 benjamins qui à 80 par
tbilissi s'était hissé car alain juppé
chapsa mais surtout d'éviter b2 ou pas
d'ailleurs le théâtre ou c4 aussi c'est
du moins dans l'esprit cap non je sais
pas non mais quévédo mais ces quatre je
trouve pas ça absurde
waters hockey façon c'est un des coups
comme ça après tu peux aussi peut-être
fair game cube et six boeufs bouche on
te donnera pas la dame de s'acquitter
changer le foot cases noires taxer si ce
bon vous coûte ce qu'il fout 17h17 c'est
ça qui peut pas trop gpat à plusieurs
choix intéressant après je ne sais pas
si je fais tour b 6 non chaque fois
c'est jamais absurde je sais mais j'ai
un bon puis font tous les genres de
coûts non méchant juste à ma 5 sur 6 bon
il va pour cribler 6 à la roquette ça ok
or donc tu appris le foot est un art
certain découle candidat et je pensais
tour b sat là dessus ouais bon alors ça
c'est la première vue je peux te dire
c'est mieux que dehors kébé de tomber si
c'est chelou mais ça doit être marrant
et moi j'attaque les pions jalada match
je crois je pense là match 3 je pense
très fort nous prendrons un coup à
gauche le coup de l'accordéon qu'as-tu
ccg coup de la corde à linge qu'eiffage
5 je pense un peu l'échéance et
d'entreprendre et et sert dame prend 1,4
après les monts fouet f3 avant ses six
matches mais on se doit le ms tu le
manges non mais tu vas manger ça
maintenant que lui il pousse son volet
c'était pas si simple car elles furent
age ii après non mais c'est chaud ces
choses là bas prix est juste parfaite
effectivement se calme un peu
ouais mais tu auras fuite oui j'ai
souffert g4 nous prendre quatre on n'est
pas heureux c'est des trucs avec tout
reprend becel tour bessette et en
métropole prendra part avec tous ceux
des cinq noms du damage trois fautes
ok on va avoir un tas sont à des
convocations à long terme siècle et
blanc le roi noir sera jamais en
sécurité partout quoi je prendrai les
noir sans hésitation assure être
pessimiste bonjour moi de rester trois
ans ferme et non la personne bien c'est
pas moins de 10,3 à jouer votre pensée
des cinq non ça me fait marrer à 4
j'aime pas queyranne tête on ramène la
dame emma est toujours des saints qui
traînent ou d'objets 5 2 et 5 tours à
cette rechute tout registre est un truc
comme ça par là bas c'est chaud dans son
dessein que tu comprends et machin je
pense faire d'albert dames 100 m
si c'est un droit ne s'était jamais
vraiment serein et il veut aller voir
nous abrite trois peut-être aussi ses
traits à rackham jours
objectivement ce mieux pour le nord
clairement il faut f3 est vite franchi 5
3 non franchement ne pouvait pas dommage
si ce que tu rentres mes affaires tête
f5
les tourbains tomber en tourbe et un
tour bien failli tomber à tomber
première mi temps et on pourra pas
familiale et fléchit trop longtemps là
j'aime pas porter font tout à tanger un
problème de connexion
ok bon ils viennent de belgique à la
tranche pas te voyais plus rien alors
c'est bon c'est bon on revoit voir faire
un g4 donc étonnant suit neuf sites
affaibli bien tout mais vous donne ses 1
h 4 mieux wimille un gps quand même
qu'ils ont su heures jusqu'à 6-6 si adam
juste de musique trois rangées 6 à 9 ans
tous au québec même encore mieux ok
ouais mais reprend le reprend ça fait
mal hein ok mais c'est intéressant comme
partie mais tout à timmy duggan le
speech est ce la folie mais bon après
l'assaut en demie ok oui oui on écoute
devant vos cigarettes
après si ça joue sur un match on finance
c'était le truc glas des traits sur la
chaîne ça mais c'était pas besoin que
ces tours 8 ben oui si c'est toujours
lui le plus c'était beaucoup mieux 5
là je connais pas ce sens chaque ya
peut-être f5 qui est jouable beaucoup
secondaires ou de quévy 6,5 direct
écoute s'appelle andy bean mais quand tu
es foulées saint roch et 6 pour se parer
des grands justes car écoute je sais pas
4 c'est important bien sûr sur deux
premiers procès il fait juste ça donc on
fait quoi être cinq
ouais ok écoute je t'apprends crois
qu'il veut ça t'enlève la dame qui était
simple un petit plan comme sa thématique
ok je sais pas ce que ça vaut 5 direct
d'ailleurs je chassais de tonner jamais
trouvé le bon après je joue pas ça tu
vas donc je peux ne pas connaître mais
juste la méthode ne pas du tout avoir vu
quoi de ma vie ce truc du coup je vais
faire une petite recherche de vos potées
ben ali fait drôle charmant grille tout
cas en train de se dépatouiller va
peut-être faire les caissettes et et d5
de parler du c5
mais j'aime bien les ouvertures et tout
s'est très bien préparé e 5 km 40
parties et great thou qui avait déjà
joué qu on ne me dira ce coup on peut
doit être au courant à saint louis en
rapide et madoff avait bougé 5 et 6
étaient repartis vers des deux ne
s'étaient pas divine du kumo suggestion
ni carlson n'avait joué que ma mère est
vers une grande nouvelle c'est doc des
partis assez récente et il y en a
quelques l'ancien meilleur chez les bons
joueurs donc et chez les bons joueurs en
fait de l'élite y est plus calme est
négatif ou qu il ya joe buck et c'est
évidemment du beau fils a fait lui même
mais aussi tout bizarre et ya krikor
qu'elle avait joué deux fois dans sa vie
on est mieux mais en fait ça devrait
toujours cfa tu vois c'est pas très joué
comme ligne bas à vérifier peut-être une
petite idée pour les noirs de sortir des
sentiers battus il ya que 40 parties
dans la base mais voilà le petit pot
théorie mais étonnant de la barre
résiste aussi bien et ce qui est
agréable face qu'il faut aussi noter ce
qu'on a oublié de dire par nos médias du
tout on fait ce qu'on veut mais je veux
dire par là que c'est un match où les
deux joueurs le prennent très au sérieux
avec jury toujours ça mais 12h les ould
bah ouais enfin il fait pas quand même à
dire entre jouage trop premier coupe et
nous sommes énervés
non mais il a fait toutes ces petrov il
ya bien eu dans les mains en fait si tu
joues contre un gris choo qui est très
sérieux que vous pas sérieux tu vas tout
le temps être mal ben bassat pas été le
cas donc il prend le match très au
sérieux il a joué des petites variantes
avec les blancs comme la trompe locaux
avec jenson que c'est vraiment des
petites idées en fait d'ailleurs ça a
plutôt bien marché dans metal droit de
joie des petits de ne pas le problème
enfin même si tu respectes un peu le
truc et il fait et surtout que lui oui
bailly c'est une chance pour lui de
jouer de tels joueurs et il veut
progresser il a faim de ça il a toujours
voulu jouer dans l'est je sais pas quand
tu joues à bois-colombes peut-être
c'était même gratuit je me demande mais
il voulait jouer
il veut jouer premier chantier tout le
temps c'était clair il ne l'avait pas
reculer et de deux ils vont avec mitton
soit la tacler les berges en tout
gratuit avec son coach je pensais que
c'était faire la cuisine
oui va aussi lui cuisiner ils peuvent
être faire des petites soirées pas rire
pour qu'ils lui mitonne des petits plats
sains mais tu vois donc en fait le fait
que c'est pas à qui des trois tirés par
le fric ou quoi penser que juste il veut
jouer d'efforts joueurs et programme
appuie l'association va être décuplée
par le fait qu'ils passent à la télé ou
ici un jeu et la voilà il ya ça qui les
jouent devant des compatriotes c'est
cool donc un jour il ya un doute
aujourd'hui je trouve plutôt sympa offre
je voudrais pas hyper bien tu as juste
parlé par ci par là mais feront de le
croiser petit a juste dit bonjour une
fois non mais jarre le dernier soir
bernie championne d'europe par équipes
on retrouve souvent dans le var et et
auquel étaient là ils étaient contents
ils étaient treize autres j'avais un nom
polonais quoi donc forcément il ne me
respecte non polonais des gens ils
passent sur brit strimko hakima cm1 ont
fait surface quand même et ça qu'il est
aussi tu es sur la scène bisri nom du
coup et avec ça décuple ses nouveaux
skis l'un est maudit
maintenant encore mais bon on va du coup
autant on peut le contacter quoi pour le
gros attaquant ukraine et mogi et voilà
et on le dit oui toujours prompt à
chiquer n'inquiète pas vite on peut
regarder sur le stream je le commente fr
elle pourra le no fake théâtre nous
prouvons les no fake tout le temps quoi
bon dénoncé pape polonais allez-vous
caruana loyer mais très sympa à turin on
était champion d'europe
enfin dernier jour enfin on va voir des
lapins et jean yvon fabiano sur un nom
italien était très heureux quoi bon du
coup je fasse plus engeance position
mais là plus que deux secondes ou deux
trucs vais te faire mariner elle était
celle de mijoter du coup web sedar il se
prend tout le champ lexical de la
cuisine que le mar mitonner les griffes
et je pense qu'il va tenter quelque
chose quand même qu'il faut c'est éviter
bien 3 quand même un ok mais voyez que
j'ai c'est un cas frontale bouffer b3 et
je vous la tac je pense donc evra henry
veut te pousser là bas mais c'est ben
[ __ ] on peut fuir avec le roi
maintenant il va payer tout et se
battent avec leurs 3 mais bon quel est
ce que tu es si menaçant de mort et
d'amd au mieux ta dam des six
mais ils jouent bien ventiler une
seconde à la pendule couac est sur le
point de plus il s'en sort très bien
incroyable non mais il ya tellement de
joueurs qui auraient complètement re5 17
rennes qui attend le contrôle show qu'il
a ce truc de bien savoir ça j'aurais
fait pareil par exemple québec
ces deux noms à oui oui parce qu'il ya
droit c'est de prendre un an et iront à
ces deux c'est peut-être lui non plus
non mais ça c'est court partout les
pions baptême à pioncer avec le roi
coupé en face après ça dépend qui valent
plus vite le matin dans le même tour
jarret calculer mais quand on me force à
pluton agression du psg sérieux que
c'était chiant ce but de mener un bon
bain chaud ils s'étaient veut plus
commenté son échec est là et là échec
échec maths c'est bon on a égalisé
bah oui on est parent résidant
maintenant la rêverie duke je me suis
compris à les fous à une eau non sinon
pas du tout qu'est ce que c'est que ça
non mais je
faudrait faire et je note on a égalisé
quand tu aimes bape et marque
ouais ça c'est tu trouves le no fake là
bas mais surtout que liverpool et plein
d'action quoi mais voit même pas payé
fort ah oui ça évidemment
ok bon 8 huîtres
ouais ouais bah c'est chaud bah oui
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est chaud
alors que dortmund en gagner à bruges
fabre le gaz à galatasaray est en train
de battre 2 0 le lokomotiv ouais je
serai aussi donc pour nos amis
supporters du lokomotiv
du coup ça placard peutch simples
attouchements non mais locomotive c'est
un club cousins ça va les animaux ouais
non il va falloir des amis m'ont une
finale qui n'a aucun ami quoi tuer pour
le dynamo tu vas tu n'as pas d'amis
évidemment mais si le west ham ça va
payer des clubs ça va enfin west ham
s'est très bien en fait restée en fait
et pour nom mais pas si tu suis la
première league anglaise et que tu sais
pas pour qui tu es ont prêté par west
ham mais cetto puce qui qui veut dire
qu'on a de vraies les mêmes goûts
cinématographiques
ouais surtout le big lebowski et oui
même niveau au dessus de tout c'est
aussi parce qu'ils les polonais du coup
en coupe d'europe
ces dernières ont des vues quoi il prend
de boire on voit être cham et je dis bon
fab faire un thé polonais quant à lui
est très heureux cette dame d un b 4
c'est un paquet ces deux voies la b3 un
peu les stones voilà la recycler n'a
rien à faire ici mais auquel il faut
qu'ils jouent bien dans ces structures
bon ok je vais tourner et qu'il évolue
et c5 déclinant ses dernières passes et
dernière partie de la cadence un
d'ailleurs devant le but ça va être
accroché de folie femmes
ok vous aime quand même beaucoup mieux
les blancs devrais je crois que c'est un
carnage déclinante est très passif tu
vas te faire enfoncer h5 machin f50i
l'étude a aucun endroit sûr pour ton roi
rénova et les trois c4 aussi faim je ne
sais pas écoute moi je ne suis pas
contre un le billy bishop ce qu'ils
veulent c'est génial dès qu'ils en ont
un peu polonais et être à quoi sert l
affaire des 3es c4eva tout ouvrir pour
l'instant il veut empêcher mais tu peux
jouer si j'ai quatre comme d'hab
évidemment mais surtout que jouer gk tu
dois jouer j 4 mais tu t'en fous doit-on
ranger parce que tu as l'espace de ce
côté et tu vois je peux attaquer que tu
as détruit
donc tu peux faire j'ai quatre top-5
possible simplement tout à fait normal
mais moi je serai en paix là c'est
énorme je serais tellement d'y goûter la
station après vous passer plein de
choses ces jeunes femmes
les baies trois c4 cclat mais tu viens
de tous les côtés cette fois attendre un
peu en fait peut être n'ont pas trouvé
de ton plan ailleurs siph et on se sent
un peu ton et la pendule et que ses
parents disent qu'on est deux secondes
et puis après tu veux tout rachat en
même temps là bas allez tout rachat
jusqu'à se faire enfin s'arrêter bien
jouer vite en fait
bah oui voilà pourquoi tour ces deux
avants et a voulu éviter quelque chose
est ce que c'est
soupçonnant très pièce remettre le caire
en d3 du coup sandra qu'une demande si
critique serait plutôt favoris en bullet
je pense qu'il favori de partout en fait
mais sur le papier de base le truc c'est
que c'est que duda il joue très bien et
du coup bah qu'est ce qu'il est vraiment
favori de quoi que ce soit nous devons
la vérité du terrain
non mais je ne peux plus me prononcer
sur ce match si tu veux je sais plus
quoi le jeu d'un fou je lâche pas d'un
faux et je ne lâcherai pas d'infos je
peux je peux rien te dire fabre tu es
tombé 2 oblige un pan du sud comme moi
quelqu'un je pense vous prépare à 5
aussi boom et ça ça peut faire mal à la
pression va s'ouvrir là
mais peut-être on veut fermer aussi mecs
essonne mais je sais pas d'ailleurs fort
bien passer un jour après sa difficulté
à me moquer mais se faisait partout
quand ça va pas taper cinq fait
peut-être détour française s'attirant et
ses pertes et vols aériens vers eux
singles il y en a trop loin c'est
possible amyris east c'est trop le gange
pour la potion mois il va pas qu'il veut
prendre 2d et voir le fou qu'elle a mené
à bien jouer moyen tour français ça de
suite on reprend des 3 1 mais d'où
d'ajustement hillary votre des petites
ressources qui perd pas comme ça j'avais
rangé si tu penses fort parce que m'en
tape sur age qui part aussi oui en fait
le jeu serait intellectuellement le même
plan d'attaqué ont fait tourner dos à
il envoie h
mais la force de 12 heures et c'est ça
c'est qu'il défend il défend il défend
quoi c'est ça déjà qu'il avait fait un
peu contré bon piont h des quoi et
encore ce qu'il va dire si ce qui va
revenir et dames 6 et de la meute asus
adam prend des six nominés
ah oui ok massage cette madame 17 à 7 h
ce matin
on souffle un ok bon qu'un point
d'avancé au troisième et de liverpool
90e + 2 le but de liverpool
en plus je suis doublement content fab
parce que j'avais parlé de mon premier
pari oui c'est un système maintenant
mais il ya un autre pari en fait dont je
t'ai pas parler mais qui était plus
petit mais c'est liverpool gagne but de
mba p1 haye du coup il est pas mal ce
but pour moi mais c'est petit mais ces
huit s'est vite je prends la coincer sur
mignot film marque le troisième va très
bien bon ok sinon la soirée contre mieux
que prévu quoi à tout d'un coup on est
heureux que le but de gervinho qui te
fait souffler non non mais battre aussi
bah oui mois doublement après je sais
pas ce n'est pas encore fini mais je
pense 91e minute on a 93 oui après c'est
fini tu peux toujours prendre un but
j'entends m est ce que c'est que ça
s'est fini à monaco en perdez dehors
dommage mais bon
dur contre l'atletico
non mais c'est beau le truck bus de mba
paix n'a pas bien senti moins pour une
fois ne m'aidait pas mal j'ai besoin
pareillement non j'suis pas tu arrives
pas tu me parles que des trucs qui se
passent bien largement parlé avant que
ça se passe je marque avant et je suis
passé je peux à mauvais mais j'suis pas
terrible mais là je ne sais pas j'étais
très heureux ce truc quelques bus de m
bavay ce que je n'ai pas senti de
liverpool la défense était pas top qui
met beaucoup de buts et je vous les
siens et loire de paris qui marque c'est
mme bâ paix tu vois ta pas qu'on s'a
meunier pas du coup on a emmené j'ai pas
pensé sûr mais là c'est pas fini encore
marc besset niveau 6 et 10 3 3 pour eux
finalement pas de chance le hasard un
liverpool c'est un peu ça c'est que ça
dans tous les sens
puis varie en plus la défense c'est pas
le top mais en fait si areola joue pas
sortez un super match 5 de weeds à dion
qui vient de naître nouveau ici donc il
vient et où vous aurez donc c'est la
seule fois où tu pourrais nous votons
donc profitez-en c'est quand même un
petit message pour ses fans
on va écouter
il ya combien de tozeur c'est la
dernière pause
ce qu'on entend ce certificat médical a
parlé tout à l'heure tu pas sûr d'en
avoir une si j'en demande une stature
toi je sais pas femmes d'arrêter truc de
tension située face à ce cas moi je ne
sais pas j'ai pu voir jouer torres est
malade pourra plus jouer en france donc
la chance j'aurais joué ailleurs déjà
germé en france où tu prends une licence
ailleurs et puis un jour en france quand
même patins à faire en fait d'ailleurs
si tu vois un souci allait prendre votre
licence à l'étranger willis ensemble
belgique à monaco d'espagne on dort en
suisse je madagascar où vous voulez qu
en italie en espagne le pays de 2 pp
cuenca mais de résistance surtout mai
mais du coup et puis même si vous voulez
économiser tout pourquoi ne pas prendre
une licence à l'étranger à la limite
c'est moins cher c'est pas plus mal
pourquoi pas si vous avez un souci est
toujours partir là dessus
licence au vatican très bien même le
partenaire nissan en tunisie pourquoi
pas ce conte allemand ce moment tu peux
pas mais en tunisie maghreb c'est bien
quoi tu supportes un peu les échecs
maghrébins au passage il est donc peu
importe où là on voit toujours une
solution au cas où bon de base dont des
contres certificat mai mais quand on
disait on a compris l'idée c'était de si
tu veux être comme sport parce que ça te
facilite les trucs pour les budgets tout
ça alors tu dois te conformer aux normes
et ils vous voilà à quoi ça a une
licence moi je sais parfaitement
effectivement d'avrillé tourner la page
de dix ans oui et alors c'est bien mais
bon on fera donc pas faire sans ok c'est
parti un truc c'est reparti fabriqué à
10 ans étaient directement auprès de la
fis doit décrire la table vont être
licenciés
actuellement extérieur plus intelligente
entre jouer puis voilà je file aucune
fédération
oui tu fais affaire ouais mais tu fais
des économies en fait tu va économiser
un peu d'argent pour un truc qui sert
absolument à rien donc c'est pas mal fab
moi ça joue ça c'est reparti donc les
noirs bon il a envie de réaliser pour
céder 5 sip est ok on voit que duda joue
contre 5 5 qui vient il à s'en prendre
aux carriers qui protège des cinq races
f1 red période 84 qui joue plus vite
femme piquée pour le cas souffrons de
sept français trois purs français 3 et
attend cahier dé 4,4 à la reprise alors
mais du coup bondoux doit mettre en
place ce qu'ils voulaient j'aime pas
trop au kg 6 pi g7
non mais 33 courant pile-poil tunis et
moins d'acheter une licence devant juste
un problème pour le certificat en fait
tu peux avoir un problème sur ce statut
peut pas faire du soir n'est pas fou
prend b3 à niamey la dame en face genre
pour courir ou quoi
l'accueil pour jouer aux échecs et a pas
de problème et on te fait pas faire sauf
certificat pour une aptitude à josé
chaque c'est quand je te dis c'est un
truc légales afin administra de
l'administratif
parce que ils se sentent obligés de
faire ça pour pour se déclarer comme
support peut-être mais sera enfin voilà
mais du coup c'est pas moyen d'aller
étrangers pour autant c'est juste envie
de voter chaque camp et mentalement apte
aux échecs
ouais après c'est une c'est la même
aberration que les échecs aux jeux
olympiques et tous ces trucs là ça se
permet de gagner de l'argent
ça permet à certaines personnes de
gagner à tous les lives et de sucre on
va partout les lives pour pour expliquer
pour expliquer vous êtes intéressé
surtout que là c'est le match
intéressant c'est un beau match bon il
ya la dame b6 est bien placé favre bah
oui mais j'attaque bessette au cas où
ouais et 17 assists plus sur asia mais
ok cavaillé va se battre genre tu prends
bien s'attaquer dès qu'arimany tué faire
damev un premier échange des dames
mairie les mieux nantis bala buluk avait
très bien cette tour à 3 pour éviter les
baies 5
mais peut-être que ça prend le 4 je
prends les 5000 clients d'ici sûr mais
le roi eux cet été
oui c'est mieux après c'est peut-être
pas gagnant mais en pratique je veux
bien croire déjà et sur moi je serais je
serai prêt se faire f 5 es tu vois il
n'a pas fait une garde son pion f pour
le moment ouais on va voir combien nous
convertissons mais c'est pas mal mais le
fou défendent tient bien pas si simple
je me souviens de la finale de wifag
contre caruana ils avaient fait nul
alors qu'elle avait fouet trois pions
contre 4 4 pions est d'ailleurs plus les
pions doublé français mais c'est comme
ça c'est un fc juste la symétrie
voilà sa gamme d'options de plus il ya
juste pas les tournées histoire d'amis
récupère incroyable le truc de cahiers
marche pas mettons g7
ok mais tu as où les pions en toi tu
reviens f3 et tu fais une bascule à
dubaï n'a pas eu tout intérêt à venir
acheter
non mais là duda s'est parfois montré
l'envié qu'un point d'écart une énorme
montagne
oui mais bon quand même quoi mais deux
ans et nul le fallait il sait très bien
que richie de votre personne
bon du coup
bah du coup qu'ils soient nouveaux cas
et ces trois riches il faut peut-être
que ces six sur lui de rock en lançant
cherche un truc bizarre de passer vingt
secondes quand même pas laisser great
choix des fois c'est du bullock voyez il
veut gagner une place en fait mais il va
gagner ou bien joué sur les points 4e il
faut sept ans mais dans tous les cas il
ya le fawcett qui va tomber sur un fil
avait versé 5 et 6 août petit rock mais
comme on jouera t congés payés ces trois
quand même viré seront tous du bellâtre
lui puissant le mec bout et en vue ce
qui est génial en fait dans ces cas là
parce qu'il double enjeu c'était
doublement récompensé après le mec un
sua il essaye de sauver sa pièce en fait
ils tentent plus de temps que toi mais
là c'est foutu je pense c'est vrai ils
ont quatre essais trop même pour un f3
tu prends des cinq rendait à prendre cet
échec
et sinon tu prends occases et thomas bon
ok nouveau break femmes dans ce match
bien joué et que tout cas écoute favre a
essayé de sa caisse qui a percé son
lancement et c6 mais ça c'est indienne
je savais s'il avait pas eu de tromperie
ans et plus est indienne j'étais au
courant
non mais ça fait un moment déjà qu'il
sera aux mains de stoner
sous les conseils de famille comme les
ordis et du mal analysé c'était une
ouverture ou le territoire est encore
assez à ya encore pas mal de choses à
trouver
sur 15 m par le théoricien tous ses skis
et mar del plata et la période n'était
prêt mais les ordis l'ont pas tout ils
n'ont pas toujours le dernier mot ouais
on est pas mal femmes on est pareil non
mais là ça va bien sur tu as causé des
caisses des cinq médailles sd4 il reste
combien de temps dans le match fabia rs
23 millions mais tu sais ça s'apprend à
peu près une minute et quelle part
partie de 3000 tekken par partie par
dont il n'a pas 50
donc il reste il reste sept suis parti
tu vois pas plus sain à des coûts qui
est bien sûr deux points d'avancé
quelque chose pour nous tous ok mais pas
fou oui bien sûr grave parce que c'est
une critique mais il n'ya pas encore les
colonnes ouverte mais la tendance est à
4 il a bien joué avec b5 tu veux tu peux
faire des français bien sûr tu prends du
cavalier mais là c'est bien d'audace du
coux et c'est déjà un autre qui est
important c'est que rich oxo c'est
sûrement gain du match
non mais pas mathématiquement mais
morale commune a fait une qualité tu
peux gagner mais ok si sa relance bien
c'est vraiment un truc important car en
cas de victoire de grisou je suis
d'accord en cas de nul à tout reste à
faire bloquer mais s'il ya évidemment
encore pire mais je pense pas qu'il va
sauver baquet et 17
c'est le danger
les aides remplissait toutes entrées
une qualité c'est quand tu gagnes tour
contre un fou auquel max klaus et sa wii
s'appelle la qualiter je peux pourquoi
en anglais d'apostasié challenge un
échange change ses parents m'ont échangé
leur faut y croire de vie il faut des 3
es ce que tu écoutes et la vidéo de vlad
nous avons déjà faire le point qu'à
quatre c4 n'a peut-être pas sûr aussi
c'est à dire sur cinq sont peut-être
aussi s'échauffent
l'agent peut critiquer la 4c 4
actuellement des goûts de l'estrie mon
sac vidéo donne pas tu sais moi je sais
mais parler d'une partie de topalov
c'est sûr topalov kamnik non on me
cherchait le deuxième joueur au nom des
six et wes et les deux joueurs du haut
qui joue l'un contre l'autre
quel aux habitudes vont être contraints
alors polonais vraiment être fou mais un
tour des trois et on dégage le voir ont
voté quoi voir me fout plein d'âme ses
204 bref tu veux je peuvent couvrir ce
me semble à son sens c'est pour fuir un
objet 4 j'aurais pas écoute perso mais
bon c'est tellement bien que la chef
quatre f 16 f 3 tours f3 tour j'ai 300
voix quoi envoie la sauce monde
la quatrième est gay c'est bien il tente
sa chance mais je pense beaucoup
beaucoup mieux clément ces deux du coup
fait très bien trois fois il faut que tu
vas avoir du danois du tour h 3 e du
coup cette façon ça se fait depuis le
début c'est très typique des douanes
lc 5 bien joué il enferme le x 800 me
faut mais ça reste les noms d'urs il des
mêmes codes ou d'asthme il est pas mal
on franklin mais il est impressionnant
ce jeune puis je vois beaucoup de
potentiel en plus tu as gers et tuchan
plus qu'à des secteurs ruraux de
progresser surtout les ouvertures je
pense mais là il aimait mieux maintenant
possiblement ok tanger troisième attaque
je pensais aussi sûrement et 2006 oued
hamimime jetta
oui mais il a préféré étant chômé on
s'engueulait tous les personnages
cette tour j'ai 5 2me 4 et
prophylactique contre autour d'eux mais
il m'a tout temps ils s'envoient l'olg
bon ça va très vite sur les taux de
matin mais ok belle séquence égalisation
à wayss & chaussées show fab
c'est chaud enfin ça joue bien c'est
tellement c'est le plus beau match de
l'année un sérieux il ya des deux puits
depuis la semaine en fait j'ai eu de
très mauvais matches en début de saison
qui était une intéressant est là depuis
le la le guérit pas le quart yakine duda
le geer imams et finalement c'était pas
terrible au début c'est c'est eh bien
voilà ton et ses matchs d'affilée
troisième beau match mais s'est mis à
jouer c'était cool assez chaud là bas
mais ouais je sais qu'on va les voir en
vrai casse un match assez extraordinaire
avec une nouvelle fois on est heureux ça
parce que c'est un de ces joueurs duda
rafraîchissant on voit pas forcément
dans les tournois de haut niveau tu as
qui vient pas pu participer à louvain ou
à ce genre de tournoi mais quand tu vois
sa performance je peux te dire sa place
ok bien joué surtout comprendre mg 5
francs mais tant pis alors moi je fais
déjà d'investissement ouais mais tu es
entreprendre un générique
bah ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais mais
bien là c'est mieux comme en 2006 de
noob
c'est très bien joué et heureusement
quelqu'un et b6 qui protège le cam à nos
propres rangs
ouais mais peut-être fou prend à deux
maintenant où tu peux pas
outre sa mort
kg coeur et je pense que les noirs sont
encore défendre et wii prend ouah ça ça
peut marcher
on se marche c'est fantastique et puis
on prend j'ai ici cela étant proche sept
matchs serrés vue des deux matchs
d'impro 9,6 mrd que les [ __ ] vu aussi
que tu joues pour faire paris nice il a
vu sa guise ou par là il fait la gueule
et se dit ok mais comment ces policiers
d'avoir vu ça mais vous a lancé
coup de chance et il est prévu et la
joie en trois secondes 4 ça ressemble
cette chance quand même voix la chance
non
et ce n'importe que ceux qui étaient
tour g8 non ok mais le parti en faisant
croire qu'il va colmater filles ont
ainsi pu te reprend à 1 kg était
d'amener de la recette attendue lettres
qu'on a vu le coût le plus beau du match
au final c'est encore chaud mois la tour
prend des tours plus tard le cari qui
arrive en f5 et au le tour e tour et
cette femme c'est une vidéo à faire
après du match s'il great food gagne le
match c'est peut-être le le moment fort
le moment le tramway
incroyable ce que j'ai 4 je pense qu'ils
attendent que le carré lisse on a fait
ça c'est un projet ouais mais demain ils
font même sens mais maintenant ils font
même sens paris reste 14e minute fab
mais ça c'est encore quattro quatre
parties 4 portes et ne prêtent même 5 1
dans lesquels quelle fin de match
haletante peut-être trop et on aurait
été nombreux tout le long du match on
encore mille trois cents femmes donc
merci à tous et n'hésitez pas à mettre
un petit polo sur la chaîne si vous
voulez voir d'autres vidéos qu'on fait
vous pouvez taper visite rime un peu
n'importe où n'importe où en fait sur
google vous tapez bitstream au lit du
vent fait même pas allé sur google chute
a pu retrouver will burton vous trouvez
la chaîne twitch pouvoir y aura tout un
lien en fait un média d fois au lieu de
faire compliqué il faut plutôt faire
simple un petit tas blitz primaube
istres ina.fr et trouve tout
et fab ça reste le feu cette partie à du
fou b6 qui arrive
nataf 4 ris quand même les joueurs qu'il
a été épuisé un homme en fait
s'enchaînent tellement mais c'est
tellement intense ac aurait par l'examen
c'est dur mais bon pour nous c'est sympa
sympa mais même à tous a commenté
toujours des trucs censé séduire des
jardins parfois juste on donne des
ventes ont fuit les fier sont prises et
parce que ok c'est déjà long mais euh
oui tu joues c'est bien pire que nos ce
moment on peut divaguer 5
mais on était quand même content de
refaire fauves et si c'est de prendre la
nuit des rois blanche m
ce concert grève leur camp c'est pour ça
que j'étais content de faire nul mais
bon ok on n'a pas trop de casse dans
chaque les noirs dont c'est pas
dramatique ce qui se passe sans qu'on
ait plus froid on effraie l'inversé très
bien ben ils sont utiles accepte pas sûr
si oui oui c'est pas tant la pression ce
qui va duda déjà fait des gros trucs en
championnat aux olympiades et ja
facebook important gens viendront
individuelles etc mais là c'est que
c'est intense enfin on dire en fait même
s'il fait le champion du monde de blitz
tu joues pas toutes les deux secondes
comme ça et tu joues tu as une posture
joutes à une pause et tu souffles un peu
entre les parties si tu joues des
parties lentes
donc ok la partie plus dur pendant six
heures peut-être mais c'est pas 6 heures
à foncer hockey est un démon la versa
hcard minute sur un coup un quart
d'heure tu peux te lèves et tu m'as vos
toilettes une balade tu vois une vers
d'autres mais ok là c'est assez intense
que le format si tu joue tout le temps
pendant trois ans pour la pression ça
peut ça peut jouer sur les premières
minutes fab au début du match peut-être
pour rentrer dans le match une fois que
tu es dans ton match fantomatique pense
plus après d'ailleurs duda sur un peu
souffert cette pression peut-être au
début parce qu'il avait train de jouer
deux premières mais depuis c'est pierre
attraper c'est peut-être un peu un
diesel ce qui est fait
ok on peut prendre ces trois quais
leucate fourchette mais dans le cas
raitt laurent lafitte est lourd à
cessieu peut-être faire des cinq mâts
mort vers quelle part des 3 300 m²
merci c'était en hiver pour 17
déterminisme remarque il veut faire ok
et sur f5 g4 et à faire grève et cinq
mois ces cinq
mais cette balade dans toi sans trop
réfléchir ce multi ça gagne en hacking
plus qu'en fait c'est faux quand je
regarde c'est finalement l'option et 7
ans le 4 août je vais faire que des
échecs et au sauvetage parce que 4 x
pour paresser sur loeb ce catamaran un
blâme et la loupe et yvon déversage
potentiel des témoins mais change pas
grand chose mais en fait il s'en fout il
va lui faire la victime en effet ils
auront fait le truc horrible qu'on
comprenne bien je pense pas il peut
prendre la nuit mais c'est à dos d'âne
juste proposé mais en fait fallu dix
proposent une cellule incroyable
sauvetage
on voit des trucs sympas dans ce but la
fête ou n'importe quoi amis il va quant
à lui passé et cette année c'est pas
très longtemps s'amuse comme ça surfer
grands draps que ça va mal se passer
bon il reste neuf minutes femme ça reste
le feu avec un point d'écart et avec un
point d'écart par rapport à gaza sont à
la porte d'à l'ombre et c'est beau sur
hill 23 parties jouées ligue 2 nuls
bailly l'on voit pas les deux il ne
ferme pas le jeu il envoie franchement
c'est peut-être le plus beau match de
speechless de tous les temps de tout le
temps de l'histoire de l'histoire du
sésame non mais franchement tu ça je
n'en rajoute pas la fin je le pense
vraiment il élimine warfare des quatre
je pense mais surtout prend quelqu'un m3
est ok je tenais à te réclament justice
et c'est pas mal joué ça a surtout prend
pions prend le pion b ne sera arriérés
non mais t'as des causes sont insiste b
5 smartphones
humble à dire excuse moi de te corriger
comprennent pas trop raide quand on
prend sept voix c'est genre d'imitation
de ce que vlad aurait pu dire de neuf là
d'imaginer un monde imaginaire ce que le
vrai vlad du coup après il peut
s'accrocher quand même taille en moins
et tu fais un petit blocage mais roide
et rauque et des combines partout la
caisse de 3 faible toutes les pièces
super active
est ce pour ça des parts de garikoitz
j'ai dit oui et où 3par essaie de faire
tourner les données vous je fais plus
confiance à gries tchouk 80 m pourtant
des quatre dont les rats très
intéressant finalement il avait un peu à
cacher son roi mais je tolère ce qui est
valide de monstres en trois une bonne
nouvelle pour les bourreaux 5 peut-être
hc ain quasiment direction match que tu
as très bien joué cette séquence
ailleurs grâce à chiba gens réfléchiront
nombreux jusque là bas un métier bien
sûr tu envie de le faire mais juste y
joue très vite comme l'embassy quoi ils
menaçaient fonds match mais c'est ce
qu'on peut faire
gridsure qui a déboursé 1 qui peut rodez
faire gaffe pour duda qui va devoir
faire un match 3 moche mais attentif des
modes du point il est très intense
combat je pense qu'ils vont être
complètement épuisée et bien le dernier
set
c'est tellement la folie quoi qu'elle
quoi ya pas tourner amassé phu yên tu
prends ça paraît chaque je pensais
qu'ils allaient prendre c'est un pari
fiac farc et c3
je pense qu'ils ratent des trucs là les
gars qui est obligé ça va tellement vite
mais si on n'est pas très bon maintenant
à ses robes beaucoup mieux pour être
bien sûr parce que lecavalier clouer le
fourreau de derrière ça reste certes en
lui même mais bon comme dit le pion à
cette chaude isa je sais pas à quel
point ce terreau où l'évangile jury qui
vous barrent est le roi s'en fout mais
je pense qu'ils auraient pu ou je pense
qu'il aurait pu faire mieux avec son
pion à 7,1 randonnée il a dû avoir un
truc duda qui l'a ratée mais là j'ai vu
à son visage fable que il a fait l'amour
il a fait une petite moue fab 1 bat
c'est quoi cette balle de match
j'imagine ouais il reste 5 minutes de
match on verra d'abord au début il ya
deux parties de sucre lui retire mais du
coup tu es toi par un mes 12 ans la
camair d'être très excité devant son
écran je crois que ça lui a fait mal la
dernière femme mais rien n'est fait bah
ouais ça fait mal c'était christophe
maïs non ça fait mal même si on
s'attache aux zones tout ça et si une
chanson à la chanson du dimanche
ce dimanche était géniale s'arrêter mais
il en avait parlé en fait sur une sur un
début de chanson du dimanche qui pourra
regarder c'est capitaine madoff
au début ils sont très heureux quoi il
sait ce sera plus une chanson de
christophe maé sont pas sûrs de la cale
mais je pense qu'il est bien ou pas
carrément à 5 dans tous les sens on
verra t-on foncé cap et la tête bien
faite perception que de se faire
attaquer c'est bien là puisque les
patients qui seront en trois sets matt
de metz à leurs justes écrasant damas et
de films non j'allais te dire qu'il ya
quatre week-ends crise ans à 4 2 me
prends tous ces quatre noms mais je veux
dire un point de plus de mot attaqué
après un accueil dans un machin ouah
comme je combattrai cardiaque ouais 3
minutes 20 femmes et il peut y avoir
encore deux parties c'est chaud de chez
shaw un point d'écart fab
c'est la folie fab
c'est la folie furieuse fait pareil
soupçonnant le choix de l'ouverture de
la part de duda wes et je trouve ça se
passe mal pour lui même celles qui les
guesninois il avait perdu aussi avec le
tours fc de ouf
mais ok petit été mieux mais que kebede
bon même je trouve ça c'était pas super
choix celle d'avant pas bien et repart
dans les zombies quoi fable c'est un
match impressionnant c'est un match dont
on se souviendra femme un magnifique
bien jeux dessins qu'ils ouvrent tout va
bien regarder le juge a gardé le chrono
et la tête repartir en grande forme
cette fois ça peut partir en overtime
fab un test très cool ça peut partir en
overtime cette histoire je crois bien
en tout cas partie décisive mais pas
forcément une balle de match pour great
choc parce qu'il reste 2 minutes 10
femmes et même en cas de nul il pourrait
rester du temps derrière rôle de cinq
fils de pièces fab et comme quatre pions
peut-être plus que trois ans plus tard
plus que deux attention fab
il ya le fou qui est revenu mais hélas
les pions la revient pour le plan
finalement la c'te folie
j'ai rien à dire c'est pas mal comment
je vais faire tous ces attaques et le
roi fab
la fnme d'infos il nous faut aujourd'hui
qu'elle offre aux tongiens je sais pas
ouais t'as tout les trucs f4 après
production enfin je préfère des blancs
mais la dame prend b6 olala lagaf
incroyable face à deux gaffes incroyable
il fallait faire dame croit qu'un v6
derrière mais même un temps franchement
dur à jouer trois pions comme ça qu'ils
avancent le peu d'activité de tes pièces
et oui de me prendre et c'est dommage de
figer une pièce mais bon on peut
comprendre
je vais très intense comme match et au
québec mais comme nous sur présence est
parti tôt reprend b5 peut-être d'un
profil donc pas du tout ils veulent
planter temps prendrait cinq en tout cas
ça suffit qui dit précédemment il a une
pièce non merci pas c'est foutu depuis
un moment mais mais ce qu'on va être en
overtime ou pas je reste 30 secondes
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on arrive en
overtime du coup et je serais même pour
qu'on passe pas la partie supplémentaire
joly fait deux fois qu'une salle
informatique
c'est la dernière femme nue l'overtime
sinon ces dernières et ben écoute
qu'est ce que c'est que ce match fab
terre est ce que c'est que ce match
alalalala n'y a pas eu dans ce match moi
je voudrais bien mais je trouve qu un
overtime
tu es mieux pour que ça se joue sur
trois parties j'aurais voulu que ça
reparte sur à 5 plus de femmes 3 +13
plus un plus un ça me rées paru plus lui
faire pour finir ce beau match ouais
mais ça fait trois heures et demie qui
joue de toute façon ils sont au même
niveau fab
mais ok du coup c'est un accident bordoy
turia keane
non c'était pas un accident et carrier
qui n'y a pas fait un si mauvais match
en réalité un parce que duda en train de
sortir un match impressionnant fab
tout va se jouer maintenant fab tout se
joue sur cette partie allait sacha sacha
qui fait un petit mouvement de tête
sacha qui qui fait un petit mouvement
donné ça chaque et mal au mal je sais
pas quand même hein et physiquement je
me sens très énervé ou g2 il est pas
content de son coup d'essai quatre ans
pour un cloud cette chaussée femme j'ai
l'impression que c'est vous dire qu'il
va se qualifier fab un couteau et un
arbre en voit lui un temps annoncé pour
10 ne te retourne pas ta mère je
retourne bien à l'équipe russe est et f5
et qu'elle prend vie that have cinq à
six fabs ouais c'est tension je sais pas
c'est chaud tu tapes a perdu en attaque
pour autant 1 h 4 h 5 jeudi un g6
ok c'est très tendu mon live à ceux du
caïd et 2 il va la perdre peut-être des
femmes c'est quasi finie
ces chauffards non mais tout peut
arriver sa raison
je peux plus commenté la fin c'est fini
j'ai perdu ma promo fois j'ai six avec
les noirs mais ok là c'est même plus du
contraire on n'est plus dans l'émotion
qu'autre chose j'en ai dans les motifs
la faim et froid je suis peut-être même
génial que ces jeunes est très compliqué
encore de vécu les parties de malades
quoi a tant parlé je sais tu peux pas il
aime ces trois quais c'est carrément du
cavalier du coeur de cette tour sera
troisième sur une pression de ouf
l'institut fait une connerie ce fim à
detroit ou wi fi et ses quatre prochains
est-ce que ça suffit c'est fini un coup
de grisou qui vient de sauter quoi il
est dégoûté crise choqué écoeuré
ok bon quoi dire il n'a pas volé son
match incroyable femme incroyable et il
n'a pas du tout les sens mais c'est vrai
qu'il est dégoûté avait toujours
moi aussi je suis déçu c'est à dire
vraiment mais bon dans mon club il
soufflé tout magnifique match mais bon
il est à + 2 je sais pas comment il a
perdu ce match fab
mais bravo à tous d'art qui a sorti un
énorme match énorme surprise fab 1 mais
il est très bon sur tout un à derna est
là le match et oui non super franchement
j'étais content d'assister à ce fabuleux
finalement tu me dis que c'est même
mieux d'avoir vu au niveau requis le
pari assez à ce point là lors de bastia
dommage mais ils n'ont pas choisi la
bonne date mais là ok très content ouais
c'est un match majuscule
il fallait un vainqueur et un vaincu
dinguerie juke qui se retrouve hugh et
côté duda et il a mérité sa victoire il
est très heureux ça fait plaisir on voit
qu'il est vraiment heureux et rivaliser
pas trop avec la maison était l'oeil et
gris chucky étant on voit là vraiment
que les joueurs soient c'est pas comme
les matchs d'egima mais où il s'en
foutait là on voit on voit vraiment
enfin tu as ça fait plaisir à voir c'est
une vraie compétition c'est sebo qua non
c'est beau c'est beau c'est bien mais
franchement bravo nous d'un jeu dont je
voudrais pas en machine de ce match
aller la gagner pas dernière c'est c'est
beau ce qu'il a fait avec de cette crise
aux dames 1 maigritude qui pourra s'en
vouloir qu'à lui même
il a quand même laissé filer ce match
qui tenez entre les mains
non elle me valère un peu au dessus mais
tout est encore mais mondou d'offres
oublier qu'il est très jeune et oui une
marge de progression et hockey s'est
passé quelque chose quelque chose qu'il
a résumé à rézé aujourd'hui surtout que
comme on disait s'il a fait coup sur
coup c'est à dire que après le match
contre carrer à qui on pouvait avoir des
doutes
oui quand tu crées une fois c'est peut
être un accident deux fois mais et en
plus avec danses et speech assfam
la différence de niveau parler vraiment
et réalisé deux performances de ce
niveau là ça donne quand même envie que
duda et des invitations dans les gros
tournois
je pense notamment aux grandes chaînes
pour l'année prochaine qui à mon avis au
lieu des matches
ben non ils vont pas les invités ils
vont réinviter à nandy vont inviter face
à thurey de pareilles cram [ __ ] tout
moi je pense quand même que avec ce
qu'on a vu sur sur 12 à titre personnel
il mériterait d'être d'être vu dans les
tons à très haut niveau il est jeune il
a 20 ans les 27 40
il vient d'un impressionnant et surtout
quand tu l'as dit dans les matchs de ce
pitch est ce plus que sur une partie
lente
tu vas vraiment la différence de niveau
parce que tu joue quasiment 30 parties
et là c'est plus du hasard c'est pas du
hasard
ben oui trente partis qui peut pas voilà
très différent au niveau ça fait comme
nakamura oui fans mais là ok j'avais
deux fois qu' il est l'amant franchement
non c'est le cadeau d'un franchement
votre travail réforme ans du joueur
polonais qui en plus passer à la télé
donc tu va repasser en pologne pour
l'image finale j'imagine donc c'est cool
quoi il fait il fait les choses pour les
échecs c'est bien nous on aura le match
de maxime contre hikaru way puis déjà
bas jeudi n'oubliez pas dans deux jours
déjà
ça va vite on a en a à rognan compte
rebondir et quoi on à rognan qu'on ne
guérit ouais mais tu feras ce que je
trouve tout autant un beau match mais là
c'était vraiment ça a été un match qui
va qui va rester dans l'est dans
l'histoire des speechs et assfam
ouais t'es beau et mais on n'a jamais eu
aussi peu de nul
bien que d'heure et puis wes a envoyé sa
portée des compliqué on a vu une gaffe
ou deux ans tourcoing sur sur 27 parties
donc c'était bien c'était cool
je suis content est ce que le mât ou
slip de gris tchouk finalement mais un
beau scénario rien mais non mais c'est
un des défauts d'interac sérieusement
malgré qu'ils aient la possibilité de
tak bac en fait un vêtement avec un ami
oui pays quand c'est flagrant évidemment
il n'y a pas de toilettes sur ce fameux
grand merci encore n'hésitez pas à nous
suivre merci vraiment a toujours des
gens qui ont suivi ce match on se
retrouve après demain on a été vraiment
très nombreux l'été 1300 à 1400 tout au
long du match
on peut en un bâtiment pendant trois
heures et demie ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment fantastique femmes il faut le
dire
donc merci de mettre fois de nous suivre
depuis si longtemps c'est grâce à vous
qu'on peut commenter ces matches il faut
pas l'oublier femmes 1 ici les gens tu
vois si on était 200 300 400 tu vois
tous les jours est ce que à chaque fois
est ce que tu as point com continuera
faire je suis pas sûr mais on est
souvent très nombreux surtout c'est
depuis cette année donc évidemment ça me
fait extrêmement plaisir et on espère
qu'on sera aussi nombreux jeudi prochain
et sur concours pour le match de maxime
le 11 octobre donc tu as dit fab c'est
peut-être le 18 je vais te dire ça toute
façon on est toujours ministre him.fr
avec le calendrier mais je vais lui dire
tu voir pour pour quitter pour pas
donner une fausse info pour ceux qui
veulent suivre tu veux le suivre le
match
encore un grand bravo à duda bravo rafa
bossi qui on n'a pas tout le temps pu
s'asseoir là on n'aime pas tous le temps
pu être assez hâte à table et sur la
chaîne visserie mossi vendredi il y aura
le marennais la 5 minute pour à troller
de folie encore une nouvelle fois pas pu
tourner trop alors je vais te dire ça
ouais c'est ça c'est long au top fab à
19 heures la nouvelle maka qui sera pas
le le plus gros quart de finale au final
sur le papier mais après franchement on
a rivalisé que ce match là sera 10 mai
ok je ne suis pas très intéressant
moment et en tous évidemment sera des
gros trucs que tu voudras nouvelle jouer
n'a qu'à en plus et pas n'importe qui
bien sûr donc non c'est cool mais là
aujourd'hui on a vraiment vécu un truc
c'était serré de bout en bout les
parties étaient animés en plus tourner
un pays assez insipide fait tout était
réuni pour soi bien on va écouter les
mecs sur ce passé une agréable soirée
bosser à fond histoire d'être tranquille
à partir de jeudi 19h pour suivre le
prochain match ça a eu les tontons